I AM ASSEMBLY WOMAN CUDDY
PETRIE-NORRIS I REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA'S SEVENTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. AND AS CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE
ON THE ORANGE COUNTY OIL SPELL
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO
TODAY'S JOINT OVERSIGHT HEARING
ON THE ORANGE COUNTY OIL SPILL
RESPONSE RECOVERY AND
PREVENTION. TODAY'S OVERSIGHT
HEARING IS A JOINT EFFORT WITH
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES AND
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
THREE ON CLIMATE CRISIS
RESOURCES ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIRS FOR WORKING
WITH ME AND MY OFFICE ON TODAY'S
HEARING. A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS BEFORE WE BEGAN. WE ARE
REQUIRING THAT MASKS BE WORN BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FOR
THE DURATION OF TODAY'S HEARING
ARE FOLLOWING OUR LAST PANEL WE
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE WILL BE
OPENING UP THE PHONE LINES AFTER
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TAKES PLACE
HERE IN THE ROOM THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY SLECT COMMITTEE ON THE
ORANGE COUNTY OIL SPILLS WEBSITE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE COAST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT FOR
HOSTING OUR HEARING TODAY THE
DISTRICT HAS ALSO BEEN HOSTING
THE UNIFIED COMMAND ALLOWING FOR
RESPONSE EFFORTS TO BE LOCATED.
AND CENTERED IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY THANK YOU TO
CHANCELLOR JOHN WEISS SPENDING
AND TO HIS STAFF FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTION TO OUR EFFORTS AND
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK ALL OF
OUR SPEAKERS AND PANELISTS FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY. FOR
TAKING TIME TO SHARE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
AS I SAID I REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA'S SEVENTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHICH INCLUDES
THE COMMUNITIES OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH. NEWPORT BEACH AND LAGUNA
BEACH WHICH HAVE ALL BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOILS BALL. IN SOME RESPECTS.
THIS SPELL HAS BEEN OUR WORST
FEARS COME TO LIFE IT'S HAD A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND ON OUR LOCAL
ECONOMY. AND I WANT MY
CONSTITUENTS I WANT ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO NOW THAT WE WILL
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS WE
WILL ENSURE THAT ATTRACT
TRAVESTY LIKE THIS DOES NOT
OCCUR AGAIN ON OUR WATCH AND WE
WILL ENSURE THAT THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTY. AMPLIFY ENERGY IS HELD
FULLY ACCOUNTABLE I ON THE
SUBJECT OF AMPLIFY ENERGY AS THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY BEFORE WE
BEGIN I DO YOU WANT TO EXPRESS
MY EXTREME DISAPPOINTMENT IN
AMPLIFY ENERGY'S REFUSAL TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING.
I AS A POINT OF REFERENCE AFTER
THE REFUGIO OIL SPILL WHICH
OCCURRED IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY IN THAT
INCIDENT TESTIFIED IN A STATE
LEGISLATIVE HEARING JUST SEVERAL
WEEKS AFTER THE INCIDENT.
AMPLIFY ENERGY EARLIER REFUSED
TO TESTIFY AT THE SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE HEARING ON
OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHTH THAT POINT
THE REQUESTED AN EXTENSION OF
TWO WEEKS. TODAY'S HEARING AS
WELL PAST THAT TWO WEEK WINDOW
SO THEIR ABSENCE TODAY IS ALL
THE MORE DISTURBING. AMPLIFY
ENERGY'S REFUSAL TO ENGAGE WITH
OUR COMMITTEE THEIR REFUSAL TO
ENGAGE WITH THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
IS EMBARRASSING AND FRANKLY IT
SENDS A VERY CLEAR MESSAGE TO
OUR COMMUNITY EIGHT THAT YOU DO
NOT CARE AND BE THAT YOU HAVE
SOMETHING TO HIDE. NEVER THE
LESS. I THEIR ABSENCE
NOTWITHSTANDING WE HAD A NUMBER
OF KEY STAKEHOLDERS JOINING US
TODAY FOR A VERY FULL AND ROBUST
AGENDA TO ENGAGE THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THE PUBLIC.
BEFORE MOVING INTO OUR HEARING
I'D LIKE TO ASK OUR OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
FOR ANY OPENING REMARKS I'D
FIRST LIKE TO INVITE THE CHAIRS
AT THE CONVENING COMMITTEES TO
OFFER WELCOME REMARKS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLIMP. THANK YOU AT AT
YOUR PETRIE-NORRIS- AND- THANK
YOU GOT YOUR RIVAS FOR YOUR
THIS HEARING TODAY. BETWEEN OUR
COMMITTEES AND I WANNA THANK ALL
OF OUR PANELISTS WERE- STEPPING
FORWARD TO SHARE THEIR EXPERTISE
AND I WANT TO BEGIN BY SAYING
THAT THAT I SHARE- ALL OF THE
COMMENTS- PROMOTE YOUR
PETRIE-NORRIS REGARDING THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY NOT BEING HERE
TODAY. IT IS EXTREMELY
DISAPPOINTING- THEY SHOULD BE
HERE- NEED TO- I'LL BE HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS- TO TELL US
WHAT THEY KNOW- AND- WE WILL
SOLDIER ON WITHOUT THEM BEING
HERE BUT- THEIR ABSENCE FROM
THIS HEARING IS- NOT GOOD FOR
THE PROCESS. AND TO LIKE KERN OF
THE CHAIR SAID WE WILL MAKE SURE
TO BE HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
CALIFORNIA'S COAST IS A PART OF
THE SOUL OF OUR STATE AND HAS
LAWMAKERS IT IS OUR DUTY TO
PROTECT IT. UNFORTUNATELY OIL
SPILLS AND- THEREFORE THESE
HEARINGS WILL CONTINUE UNTIL WE
REMOVE ALL CONTROL M.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SOURCES FROM
OUR COAST WE CAN IMPROVE
POLICIES IN RESPONSE BUT THERE'S
ALWAYS GOING TO BE A RISK. AS
LONG AS WE PUMPED AND TRANSPORT
PETROLEUM- THROUGH THE WATER. HI
THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA
TO BE DOING IT IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND AS THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE ON THE
CLIMATE CRISIS RESOURCES ENERGY
AND TRANSPORTATION. I FOCUSED ON
PROTECTING OUR COAST AND
REDUCING PETROLEUM USE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH CALIFORNIA'S
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS
AND SIMPLY PROVIDING FOR A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT IN A CLEANER
ENVIRONMENT. JUST THIS YEAR WE
INCREASED FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE STAFF TO PREVENT OIL
SPILLS. WE ALSO SPENT FIFTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO PLUG AND
ABANDON OFFSHORE WELL IN SANTA
BARBARA GIVE YOU AN IDEA- I JUST
HOW COSTLY- THIS KIND OF
INSTRUCTION FOR STRUCTURE CAN BE
THE TOTAL STATE COSTS IS SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND THAT'S NOT
EVEN THE ENTIRE. COST OF THE
PROJECT WITH AGING OIL
INFRASTRUCTURE WE MUST ENSURE
THAT RESPONSIBILITY RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE TO
PROTECT OUR COAST AND ARE INLAND
AREAS FROM OIL DESTRUCTION.
ADDITIONALLY THIS YEAR WE HAVE
ALLOCATED THREE POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS TO ENCOURAGE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND I
SECURED ONGOING FUNDING TO
PROTECT MARINE LIFE AS WELL.
WELL WE CAN CONTINUE TO SPEND
DOLLARS TO TRANSITION TO A CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE WE ALSO NEED TO
ADOPT STRONG POLICIES. TO
PREVENT CATASTROPHIC SPILLS IN
THE FUTURE AND SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO PARTNERING WITH EVERYONE WHO
IS PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING IN IDENTIFYING AND
ADOPTING THESE POLICIES. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
FOR TAKING THE LEAD AND
ORGANIZING THIS HEARING AND OF
COURSE TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM-
FOR JOINING US ARE YOU A
SHOCKING AS THIS BILL IS IT
SEEMS LIKE IT HAS BECOME A
REGULAR OCCURRENCE THAT WE HAE
ACCIDENTS IN THE PETROLEUM
SUPPLY CHAIN. WE'VE HAD THE
LEGISLATURE HAS HAD MANY
HEARINGS AND LEGISLATION
REGARDING THESE ISSUES AND EACH
TIME WE HAVE MADE IMPROVEMENTS
TO SPILL PREVENTION AND RESPONSE
HOWEVER OIL ALWAYS FINDS NEW
WAYS TO GET INTO THE ENVIRONMENT
TO THE POINT THAT'S BILL SEEM AN
AB INEVITABLE. IN THIS CASE WE
HAVE A MARINE SPILL ORIGINATING
IN FEDERAL WATERS WERE A
PIPELINE SUFFERED SIGNIFICANT
DISPLACEMENT WHICH WAS
APPARENTLY UNDETECTED WHERE THIS
BILL WAS NOT IMMEDIATELY
DETECTED AND REPORTED AND WHERE
THE RESPONSE WAS DELAYED. BY
LAGS IN REPORTING AND DARKNESS.
AS BAD AS THIS BILL HAS BEEN FOR
THIS COMMUNITY WE GOT VERY
LUCKY. IT COULD HAVE BEEN MUCH
WORSE THE COMMUNITY AND MANY
OTHER COASTAL AND INLAND
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
REMAIN AT RISK DUE TO THE
INHERENT RISKS OF OIL PRODUCTION
AND DELIVERY COMBINED WITH THE
AGING INFRASTRUCTURE OUTDATED
POLLUTION CONTROLS AND AN
ADEQUATE MAINTENANCE. AND THE
FACT IS THAT THESE RISKS PALE IN
COMPARISON TO THE DAILY HEALTH
IMPACTS OF PETROLEUM PRODUCTION.
REFINING AND USE EVEN IF
ACCIDENTS ARE ELIMINATED USING
OIL AS INTENDED UNFORTUNATELY
KILLS PEOPLE ON THE PLANET. AND
LOW INCOME AND MINORITY
COMMUNITIES SUFFER THE MOST SO
LET'S LEARN TODAY FROM THIS BILL
AND ONCE AGAIN TRY TO SHARPEN
OUR ABILITY TO PREVENT AND
RESPOND TO ACCIDENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER INVEST
UP WITH OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LIKE TO MAKE A MARK
FIVE MISTER MERCY TO BEGIN WITH
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A CHAIR
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR CONVENING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT HEARING I
REPRESENT. OPEN TOGETHER WITH
YOU I REPRESENTED A COASTAL
DISTRICT OF FROM MANHATTAN BEACH
DOWN THROUGH PALACE BIRDIES AND-
YOU KNOW WE ARE CONSTANTLY
REMINDED WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR OUR
BEAUTIFUL COASTLINE THAT THIS
IS- ONE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST PRECIOUS
RESOURCES AND THAT WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE. TO PROTECT
IT. I SUPPORT BANNING ALL
OFFSHORE DRILLING I BELIEVE
THAT- AS THE REST OF THE WORLD
IS MOVING TOWARD PHASING OUT OUR
RELIANCE ON FOSSIL FUELS AND TO
RAMP UP. RENEWABLE ENERGY.
THERE'S JUST NO GOOD REASON TO
CONTINUE WITH OFF SHORE OIL
DRILLING NOW I UNDERSTAND AS A-
CHAIR BLOOM INDICATED THAT THE-
SHUTTING DOWN EXISTING OIL
OPERATIONS IS EXTREMELY COSTLY
WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
OPERATORS. UP PAY THE BILLS TO-
PHASE OUT AND TO SHUT DOWN THESE
PLATFORMS TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THESE ACCIDENTS
BUT IN THE MEANTIME- MADAM CHAIR
I LOOK FORWARD TO LEARNING MORE
ABOUT. YOUR EXPERIENCE THE
ORANGE COUNTY TO EXPERIENCE WHAT
THE LATEST IS THE LATEST-
ECOLOGICAL DISASTER THAT COMES
FROM OFFSHORE DRILLING THANK YOU.
HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
THANK YOU AND AGAIN THANK YOU TO
CHAIR PETRIE-NORRIS FOR
CONVENIENCE HERE TODAY THANK OU
CARE BERMAN CHAIR RIVAS- FOR
MAKING THE JOINT HEARING WE KNOW
WE'RE NOT GONNA SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM ALONE AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY- I THINK I WANT
TO THANK EVERYBODY WHO'S
PARTICIPATING TODAY THE
PANELISTS THE PRESENTERS. WERE
INTENDING IN PERSON AND REMOTELY
BUT I RECOGNIZE THAT THE CHAIN
OF EVENTS LEADING UP TO THE
RUPTURE OF THE PIPELINES OF
STUFF REMAIN UNDER ACTIVE
INVESTIGATION I AM HOPEFUL WE
CAN GET SOME INSIGHT TODAY INTO
HOW AND WHY THIS OCCURRED. THE
BILL HAS BEEN YET ANOTHER
REMINDER THAT THERE'S NO 100%
SAFE WAY TO EXTRACT OIL OFF OUR
COASTLINE FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
THAT MEANS MOVING FORWARD OUR
TASK IS TO IDENTIFY WAYS TO
MITIGATE THE RISKS TO OUR
COASTLINE AS WE CYCLE DOWN THE
OPERATIONS PERMANENTLY. I
REPRESENT NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO
FROM THE ORANGE COUNTY BORDER
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO ENCINITAS
AND CARDIFF AND THIS IS ALTHOUGH
THE SELECT COMMITTEE IS CALLED
THE ORANGE COUNTY OIL SPILL
RESPONSE IT'S AFFECTED SAN DIEGO
WE HAVE EVERY DAY I GET TEXTS
FROM PEOPLE THE TAR BALLS
WASHING UP ON A BEACH AND THE
IMPACT THAT HAS ON OUR ECOSYSTEM.
SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
RISK THAT IT POSES NOT JUST TO
THE PLACE OF ORIGIN AND THAT
IMMEDIATE AREA. BUT OUR ENTIRE
COASTLINE. AS WELL MANAGED. AND
HOW WE PREVENT SUCH EVENTS BUT
ALSO AN IMPROVING HOW WE
RESPOND. I'M ALSO LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING MORE ABOUT
HOW WE DID IN OUR RESPONSE TO
THIS CRISIS. WHERE THINGS WENT
RIGHT AND WHERE WE CAN IMPROVE-
THANK YOU AGAIN TO EVERYBODY
PARTICIPATING TODAY AND THANK
YOU AND I'M SURE FOR THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN.
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD
MORNING IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
WITH EVERYBODY HERE TODAY I
CURRENTLY REPRESENT- BOTH OF
BOTH THE CHICO STATE PARK ESTATE
BEACH AND ALSO SUNSET BEACH
SUNSET BEACH DID NOT HAVE THE
OIL SPILL BUT WE HAVE HEARD OF
SOME POTENTIAL AND ACTUALLY SOME
TALL BARS HAVE GONE DOWN
DIRECTION HOWEVER BOTH A CHICA
STATE BEACH. HAS HAD THE OIL
SPILL. OF WHICH IS RIGHT NEXT TO
HUNTING BEACH. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THEM OUR COMMITTEE CHAIR
FOR GATHERED US ALL HERE TODAY.
TO DISCUSS ON. WHAT HAPPENED HOW
DID IT HAPPEN. WHERE ARE WE AND
WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE. AND I
ALSO WANNA THANK A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE TRAVEL. TO
ORANGE COUNTY FOR THIS MEETING.
UPON LEARNING OF THIS BILL I WAS
SURPRISED THE DELAY TO ALERT
LOCAL OFFICIALS TO HELP HER. AND
THE DELAY IN NOTIFYING THE
PUBLIC OF THIS BILL EVENT. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO BE INFORMED AND PROVIDE THE
MOST UP TO DATE INFORMATION TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND TO THE
PUBLIC. ESPECIALLY IN EVENT LIKE
THIS THAT POSES A POTENTIAL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
RISKS TO NOT ONLY RESIDENTS BUT
TO ALSO WILDLIFE ALIKE. IN THE
WILDLIFE WAS EXTREMELY BORED TO
OUR DISTRICT BECAUSE WE HAVE.
BOTH THE CHICA CONSERVANCY. I
ALSO WANT TO ASK- MADAM CHAIR IF
NOT TODAY BUT IN THE FUTURE WILL
HOLD ANOTHER HEARING IS THAT WE
HEARD NOW MANY SPECULATION
DOESN'T KNOW THAT INVESTIGATIONS
TO GROW CURRENTLY GOING ON. BUT
THE CARGO SHIP. THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH IN THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES
SHOULD HAVE BEEN HERE AS WELL.
BECAUSE REGARDLESS OF HOW WOULD
WE KNOW THAT THIS OIL SPILL. BUT
HOW WOULD COST HOW IT WAS
BECAUSE A LOT OF COMMENTS HAS
BEEN MADE ALREADY. AND REPORTED.
THAT IT WAS A CARGO SHIP.
THERE'S TOO MANY CARS THERE
SHOULD BE NONE ALL THERE'S OVER
A HUNDRED CARGO SHIP. ON THE
COASTLINE OF ORANGE COUNTY
BEACHES AND THAT STARTS WITH MY
DISTRICT IS WHO WE WRE WHAT
WERE RIGHT NEXT TO LONG BEACH
PORT. IN ADDITION WE SHOULD ALSO
HEAR FROM THE OIL INDUSTRY. THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN INVITED SO
SHOULD BE THE LABOR. THE GROUP
AS WELL BECAUSE WE NEED TO HEAR
FROM THEM ON HOW WE CAN GO
FORWARD EXPRESSION WHEN IT COMES
TO THE CARGO SHIP AREA. AND
INDUSTRY AND WE NEED TO MOVE
THESE CARGO SHIP OUT. AGAIN I'M
HOT B. L. I'M HOPING THIS
COMMITTEE. AND CONTINUED TO WORK
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO BEING A
PARTICIPANT. AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENT AND DIED.
AT THANK YOU FOR IT FOR THOSE
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS AND- I
THINK THAT IF YOU IN AND OUT
WITH THE FOLKS WHO ARE WATCHING.
THIS IS THE FIRST IN A SERIES OF
HEARINGS AND WE WILL CERTAINLY.
HAVE ADDITIONAL HEARINGS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE WHICH WILL DIVE INTO A
MANY OF THOSE THOSE TOPICS THAT
TODD THAT YOU'VE HIGHLIGHTED. AT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES. THANK OR
HOLES FOR HAVING. US HERE TODAY
AND MY TELEPHONE. YES SIR I
THANK OUR HOSTS FOR US TODAY AND
TELL US REMEMBER FOR TWO DOWN TO
ORANGE COUNTY. FOR THOSE WHO DO
NOT KNOW ME MY NAME IS LAURIE
DAVIES AND I HAVE THE PLEASURE
OF SERVING THE SEVENTY THIRD
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHICH INCLUDES
THE CITIES OF DANA POINT AND SAN
CLEMENTE- BULK NEGLEY IMPACTED
BY THIS DISASTER. I AM GRATEFUL
TO THE SPEAKER AND OFFICIALS WE
WILL HEAR FROM TODAY ABOUT THIS
BILL AND WHAT IS BEING DONE TO
CLEAN UP AND PREVENT OTHER
DISASTERS. I KNOW MUCH OF
TODAY'S TOPIC WILL BE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS HOWEVER I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE WILL ALSO
TOUCH UPON THIS WHICH IS
ECONOMIC DISASTER FOR COUNTIES
WELL. LOST IN THE MEDIA COVERAGE
WAS THAT CALIFORNIA'S TOURISM
CAPITAL MANY VERY SMALL
BUSINESSES LIKE HOTELS
RESTAURANTS AND FISHING
COMPANIES WERE FORCED TO SHUT
DOWN FOR DAYS AND WEEKS BECAUSE
OF THIS BILL. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE ANY NEW POLICY OR LAWS ARE
PRODUCED RELATED TO THIS
INCIDENT INCLUDING ECONOMIC LENS
AS WELL. AS A ONE TO MAKE SURE
THAT ANY DECISIONS REGARDING
LEGISLATION MOVE FORWARD AS
COMMONSENSE DECISIONS AND THAT
THIS WON'T END UP BEING A BAD
IMPACT ARE HAVING BAD
REPUTATIONS NOT ONLY FOR THOSE
THAT LIVE ON THE COAST LINE BUT
FOR CALIFORNIA AS A WELL. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND I'M
VERY EXCITED TO GET STARTED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER UP WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO CALL UP OUR FIRST PANEL WE'RE
DOING A BIT OF A HYBRID SO IT'LL
BE SOME AT PANELISTS JOINING US
HERE IN PERCENT AND SOME WILL BE
JOINING US VIRTUALLY. ARE AT
PANELISTS BIRDS THE FIRST PANEL
ARE AT CHECK BONHAM THE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA'S DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. THOMAS COLIN
JUNIOR FROM THE OFFICE OF OIL
SPILL PREVENTION AND RESPONSE
CAPTAIN GARY LLEWELLYN FROM THE
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S.
DEPARTMENT HARBOR PATROL BUREAU.
THERE CAN CAR FROM THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON. I GET BROWN FROM
ORANGE COUNTY COAST KEEPER. UP
WITH THAT I THINK WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND THAT BEGIN IF WE'VE
GOT DIRECTOR BONHAM. ON OUR
VIDEO AT LINK. DR BONHAM WILL
BEGIN WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. Q.
CHAIR COUNTY LOS LONELY JUST
CONFIRM YOU CAN HEAR ME AND SEE
ME. IT IS A LITTLE BIT FUZZY.
QUITE A BIT AT THE. I DON'T
THAT'S ON MY END- ON THE MEDIA
AND THEIR. SO I DIRECTOR WE
CAN'T REALLY HEAR YOUR AUDIO.
CAN YOU HEAR ME CLEARLY. I
UNDERSTAND AND I PASSED ONLY A
TEN TASK EARLIER WE EXPERTS.
OKAY I. NOT SURE THERE'S A WAY.
HOME PHONE NUMBER YEAH CAN YOU
PROP STYLING WE CAN. YEAH YOUR
THEIR DIALING NUMBER THAT WE CAN
GET TO DIRECTOR BONHAM. YOUR
TECHNICAL STAFF RAN AS THE GROUP
CHECK IN THIS MORNING AND
CONFIRMED SO I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER IT'S ON YOUR AND OUR-
DIRECTOR WE CAN'T HEAR YOU AT
ALL NOW. LET'S GO AHEAD AND
START WITH. MR CULLEN FROM THE
OFFICE OF OIL SPILL PREVENTION
AND RESPONSE AND- I ENTER IF YOU
CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO REPEAT THE
CONNECTION WITH DIRECTOR BONHAM
THEN WILL TURN TO HIM THAT. ARE
MISTER CULLEN ARE YOU. ON THE
LINE THANK YOU MANAGER ON
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS- I'M GONNA
BRING MY PRESENTATION RIGHT NOW
AND. RUSHERS WE ALSO ARE HAVING
STUDENT AT SORRY MR CALL AND
WE'RE HAVING SOME ISSUES WITH
YOUR AUDIO AS WELL. OUR NEWSEUM
AND VIRTUAL REALITY. THROUGH THE
WORK. WHEN WE HEAR FROM THE
JERSEY SHORE. SANDERS KINDA
SORTA. OUR SOUND CHECK. ONE TWO
THREE. I THINK WHAT WE'LL DO IS
I CAN YOU FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
GOING INTO CAN YOU FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE TACK
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED WITH THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE HERE JOINING US IN PERSON.
ALL RIGHT AT OKAY WITH THAT- WE
WILL TURN TO OUR IN PERSON
GUESTS AND WE WILL FIRST HEAR
FROM CAPTAIN THE WELLAND IS
JOINING US FROM THE ORANGE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
CAPTAIN THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU CAN HEAR ME. OKAY ARE
YOU GUYS THANK YOU FOR- FOR
HAVING HERE TODAY- KEPT IN YOUR
LONG GEORGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT I AM THE HARBORMASTER
FOR THE COUNTY OF ORANGE WHICH
MEANS I'M IN CHARGE OF ALL THREE
HARBORS PROVIDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT- KNOWING FOR THE
HARBORS WITH THE COASTLINE BUT-
IN ORANGE COUNTY. TO HARBOR
PATROL ALSO DOES MARINE
FIREFIGHTING SEARCH AND RESCUE
WORK ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AND WILDLIFE PROTECTION- WE HAD
ALL THOSE THINGS SO IT'S JUST A
MORE COST EFFECTIVE FOR US TO DO
EVERYTHING TO HAVE. ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT ENTITIES ON THE WATER-
I'M HERE TODAY TO HELP THE
TRANSCRIPT ANY. INFORMATION I
CAN WITH THE- DATE OF THAT
INCIDENT AND I THINK ABOUT IT IS
YOU KNOW GO OVER REAL QUICKLY.
OUR. ROLE FROM A RIGHT AT THE
BEGINNING. APRAKSIN FIVE THIRTY
PM ON FRIDAY OCTOBER FIRST. THE
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT HARBOR PATROL BOATS
WERE ENGAGED WITH THE HONEY TO
BEACH- SHOW. THAT WAS HAPPENING
IN THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON BEACH-
DEPUTIES ON SCENE. OVERHEARD LOW
POWERED RADIO TRANSMISSIONS OVER
THE MARINE RADIO OF AN UNUSUAL
ORDER AND POSSIBLE FUEL SPILL IN
THE WATER. IN THAT AREA. SO
DEPUTY SELF DEPLOYED TO THE AREA
BUT BEING AS AT THE AIR SHOW WAS
COMING TO AN END MANY BOATS WERE
LEAVING. AND SO IT TURNS UP THE
WATER AND SO THEY THOUGHT MAYBE
A BOAT IS. WHAT WE CALL BURPED
OUT AS A SMALL AMOUNT OF FUEL
FROM ITS BILL WHICH- AND- AND
EXPLAIN THAT LATER IF YOU LIKE-
IN IT WOULD JUST TURNED UP BY
THE PERFECT PROPS OF EACH OF THE
VOTERS ARE TAKEN OFF. SO AFTER
DOING A SELF. DEPLOYED PATROL
JACK THEY'RE UNABLE TO LOCATE
HIS BILL SO THIS WENT BACK TO
THEIRREGULAR POSITION-
PROVIDING SECURITY FOR THE AIR
SHOW. UNTIL IT ENDED IN OF. AND
THEN RETURNED BACK TO THE
STATION. AT ABOUT SIX FIFTEEN
PM- HARBOR PATROL DISPATCH.
COULD OVERHEAR A CARGO SHIP
REPORTING A POSSIBLE FUEL SPILL.
A RECORD REPORTING A SHEEN IN
THE WATER- TO THE U. S. COAST
GUARD. AND THEN ABOUT EIGHT PM
THAT NIGHT THE US COAST GUARD
CONTACTED US VIA TELEPHONE-
NEWPORT BEACH RICKARD DISPATCH
CENTER REQUESTED ASSISTANCE.
WITH LOCATING A POSSIBLE OIL
SPILL. AND- IN BEING IT WAS
ALREADY DARK OUTSIDE IT'S
EXTREMELY HARD TO SEE YOU CANNOT
TELL THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS
GUY IN THE OCEAN BECAUSE
EVERYTHING JUST LOOKS BLACK AND
SO TRYING TO LOCATE IN A BLACK
SUBSTANCE ON THE WATER WOULD BE
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE- IN IT- SO. WE
AGREED WITH THE COAST GUARD THE
NEXT MORNING THE SET UP AROUND
SEVEN THIRTY SO SOMETIME BETWEEN
SEVEN THIRTY AND SEVEN FORTY
FIVE. US COAST GUARD HAS MATT
INVESTIGATOR ORDERED OUR ONE OF
OUR BOATS OUT OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH AND SET OUT AND IT STILL
DURING THE DAYLIGHT STILL TOOK
US AN HOUR TO LOCATE. THE A
PLUME OF OIL ABOUT A HUNDRED
YARDS IN DIAMETER. AND WHEN IT
WHEN WE WERE OUT THERE
COLLECTING SAMPLES ARE SHOULD
SAY THE COAST GUARD WAS
COLLECTING SAMPLES. OF THAT IS
WHEN WE HEARD MORE RADIO
TRAFFIC- FROM A MARINE RADIO
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO.
AND IN REPORTING A LARGER OIL
SPILL ABOUT FIVE MILES OFF. THE
TWENTY TWO BEACH SO WE WENT OUT
THERE AND LOCATED THAT LARGE OIL
SCHOOL AT THAT TIME. AND SO WE
ASKED A- HELICOPTER ONE OF OUR
SHIPS HELICOPTERS TO FLY OVER TO
CAPTURE VIDEO OF IT. AND TO
TRYING TO DETERMINE THE SOURCE
AND- IN FROM COMING DOWN COAST
UP WE COULD SEE IS LIKE A FUNNEL
EFFECT. AND SO WE KIND OF
PINPOINTED FROM THE START WHERE
WE BELIEVED THAT IT MIGHT BE
FROM. AND MY SURGEON ON DUTY-
WENT WELL ABOVE AND BEYOND AND-
NOTIFIED THAT- LOOKED ON A CHART
AND SAW WERE- THE GPS LOCATION
OF WHERE WE BELIEVE THE SOURCE
WAS COMING FROM AND NOTIFY THE
OIL PLATFORMS. BUT NINE THIRTY
AM. ON SATURDAY THE TWO THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE- AND
WHAT'S- THE- I. LEAGUE IN THEIR
SYSTEM. AND THEY SAID THAT THEY
WERE TO DO THE PROTOCOLS AND
THAT'S THE- IN BY TEN THIRTY-
THE COAST GUARD CALLED US AND
SAID THAT- THE VERIFIED THAT THE
WORLD'S. OIL SPILL IS COMING
FROM THEM AND THAT THEY ARE
TAKING OVER THE INVESTIGATION.
IN IN THE IN THAT HOURS TIME WE
HI I HAVE MY DISPATCH TEAM
NOTIFY. ALL THE CITIES ON THE
COASTLINE. OF ORANGE COUNTY OF A
POSSIBLE OIL SPILL THAT MAY BE
AFFECTING THE- ORANGE COUNTY.
AND ALSO IN TO INCLUDE OCEANSIDE
AND SAN DIEGO IN THOSE CALLS
BECAUSE KNOWING THE WITH THE
TIDE. IT'S I KNOW IT'S GOING TO
GO TO- THINGS HALFWAY BETWEEN
CATALINA IN ORANGE COUNTY IN UP
IN SAN DIEGO- BOATS AND OTHER
THINGS I THINK- I THOUGHT THEY
SHOULD NOT ALL. OF. THE POSSIBLE
BUT WILL STILL HAVE THEIR WAY.
IN THE TWO AFTER. THAT THE WE DO.
WE JOIN THE MATTER TEAM AND
HELPED OUT HOWEVER WE CAN.
PROTECTING THE HARBORS IN. IN
THE CLOSING DOWN. BELIEVE US
SUNDAY I DON'T I DON'T REMEMBER
THE TOP OF MY HEAD- HAVE JUST
PROTECT OIL FROM COMING IN- TO
OUR HARBORS. MISFIT THANK YOU
AND I THINK WHAT WE'LL DO IS
WE'LL BURKE WE'LL HEAR FROM ALL
OF OUR PANELISTS AND THEN JUMP
INTO QUESTIONS AND DISCUSSION.
ARE JERRY BROWN AT TWENTY KNOTS
FROM ORANGE COUNTY COAST KEEPER.
THANK YOU. AND CHAIR MY NAME IS
GERRY BROWN EYED THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
ADDRESS YEAR TO DATE I AM THE
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF ORANGE
COUNTY COURSE KEEPER AND ON
DECEMBER FIRST I'D I'D GET SWORN
IN FOR MY SEVENTH THREE YEAR
TERM ON THE PORT OF LA LONG
BEACH- OSCAR. COMMITTEE IN THE
HARBOR SAFETY COMMITTEE FOR THE
PORT. OKAY FIRST OF ALL. I WANT
TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF THIS
PANEL IN THE ORGANIZATIONS THEY
REPRESENT- ANY OIL SPILL IS A
CATASTROPHE EMITTERS TREMENDOUS
IMPACTS FROM- BUT HAS BEEN HAVE
HAS BEEN SAID PREVIOUSLY THIS
COULD HAVE BEEN WORSE. AND SO WE
DON'T MINIMIZE IT BUT- WE'RE
LUCKY IT COULD HAVE BEEN WORSE-
I HAVE NOTHING BUT COMPLIMENTS
FOR THE QUICK ACTIONS THAT WE'RE
TAKING THE EXPEDIENT CLOSING OF
THE BEACHES AND HARBORS. UNTIL
MORE INFORMATION WAS KNOWN-
INFORMATION WAS PROVIDED THE
PUBLIC THERE WAS GREAT
TRANSPARENCY M. THERE HAS BEEN
SINCE THAT DAY IN CONTINUES
TODAY DALY REPORTED HIMSELF.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL THE ACTIONS
OF OUR FOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE OF THE COUNTY
OF THE CITY- EVERYBODY DID THEIR
JOB AND THEY DID IT WELL SO
THANK YOU. THERE ARE TWO
STANDARDS THAT I THINK YOU HAVE
THE TOOLS TO USE IN THE- THEIR
STANDARDS CONTAINED IN THE
CALIFORNIA'S NINETEEN NINETY US
FOR- STATUTES THE OIL. SPILL
RESPONSE AND RESTORATION ACT ONE
STANDARD IS BEST ACHIEVABLE
PROTECTIONS WE USE THAT TODAY IN
WATER QUALITY WE JUST CALL IT
BEST AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY BUT-
IT DOES EXIST AND IT SAYS THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. WILL HOLD OIL
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS TECHNOLOGY AS A
MESSAGE AS SENSORS AS
REQUIREMENT- INVOLVES THAT THE
OIL COMPANIES WILL IMPLEMENT
THAT. M. AFTER THIRTY ONE YEARS
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE SHE AN
EVALUATION- OF ACTUALLY WHAT HAS
BEEN CHANGED BECAUSE WHEN YOU
SEE BLOOMS AND DISPERSANTS
THAT'S OLD TECHNOLOGY. AND SELF
YEAH I THINK I THINK THAT'S A. A
STARTING PLACE- THE THING IS FOR
MEDICATION WE FIND IN MOST
REGULAR RATE REGULATIONS THAT
ARE THERE'S ALWAYS AN ECONOMIC
BALANCING WHAT WHAT CAN YOU DO
GOOD WHAT CAN YOU DO TO MITIGATE
AS LONG AS IT'S REASONABLE COST
EFFECTIVE. SPECIFICALLY FOR
MEDICATION IN THE OSCAR ACT. DID
IT UP DOES NOT- IN AND IT
SPECIFICALLY STATES ECONOMICS
WILL NOT BE A FACTOR. THAT
MITIGATION MUST BE DONE
REGARDLESS OF THE COST AND IF
THE OPERATOR DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY THEN. THE OIL INDUSTRY
SHOULD CHIP IN AND SO THOSE ARE
TWO VERY OF THE INCREDIBLE OF
STANDARDS THAT WERE NEGOTIATED
WITH THE OIL INDUSTRY BY. THE
MEMBERS OF THE TABLE IN NINETEEN
NINETY M. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THE ROBUST NOW AS THEY
WERE. INTENDED TO BE IN NINETEEN
NINETY. IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S
BEEN SIX MAJOR OIL SPILLS SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE. M. I
GUARANTEE TO FIX I GUARANTEE
THERE WILL BE MORE OIL SPILLS. I
ALSO GUARANTEE THAT. THE
PLATFORM OPERATOR RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE OIL SPILL YOU'LL
PROBABLY HAVE NEVER HEARD OF.
THE POINT BEING THAT LARGE
COMPANIES ARE GONE. SHELL EXXON
UNION ARE CO AND CHEVRON WHO
BUILT THESE ARE GONE THERE'S
MAYBE SOME UNDERLYING LEASES BUT
ESSENTIALLY THEY'RE NOT
OPERATING IN YOU HAVE MORE FAR
MORE MARGINAL COMPANIES
OPERATING IN YET YOU KNOW THE-
THE IMPACTS OF AN OIL SPILL ARE
SO GREAT. I JUST WONDER IF WE
COULD DO SOMETHING BETTER. IF
THE REMAINING TWENTY SEVEN
PLATFORMS ARE GOING TO START
DECOMMISSIONING A CLEAR PATH TO
EXPEDITE DECOMMISSIONING MUST BE
DEVELOPED. CALIFORNIA ONLY HAS
THREE PLATFORMS OPERATING
PLATFORMS PLUS HOLLY WHICH WAS
ABANDONED BY RANOCO. TWENTY
THREE YEAR IN FEDERAL WATERS WE
HAVE TWO OPTIONS. IN COMPLETE
REMOVAL RETURNING THE BOTTOM TO
ITS NATURAL STATE AND WE HAVE
RIGS TO REEFS AND FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT
RICK ST- I WAS INVOLVED WITH THE
WITH THE ORGANIZATION THAT
CALIFORNIA ARTIFICIAL REEF
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM AND WE SPENT
TEN YEARS GETTING THE
LEGISLATION- AT THE TIME TO BE
SPEAKER HERTZBERG. OF IS
SPONSORED THE LEGISLATION IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE ARNOLD- GOVERNOR
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER SIGNED AND
IT HAS NEVER BEEN IMPLEMENTED
REGULATIONS WERE NEVER PUT
TOGETHER BECAUSE THERE'S TIME
FRAMES IN THE LEGISLATION THAT
MAKE IT INFEASIBLE THE
COMMISSION WITHOUT WOULD GO BACK
INTO FIX THAT LEGISLATION BUT
THAT WAS NEVER DONE AND I THINK
OF SERIOUS WORK WOULD BE TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THE STATUTE AB TWENTY
FIVE OH THREE- JUST VERY
EXTREMELY BRIEFLY. IT REQUIRES A
AB ROBUST BIOLOGICAL ASSESSMENT
OF EACH ROOF TO DETERMINE IF
THEY IN FACT ARE PRODUCING
PRODUCTIVE HABITATS IN WEEKS- IF
SHOW THEIR THE PROPOSAL IS TO
CUT HIM OFF AT EIGHTY FEET BELOW
THE SURFACE CALCULATE THE COST
SAVINGS THE OIL COMPANY SAVES BY
NOT REMOVING THEM. AND THEY
BASICALLY WRITE A CHECK TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA 465285% OF
THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WILL.
GO TO COASTAL RESTORATION. THE
STRUCTURE BELONGS TO PROPERTY OF
THE STATE IN THE OIL COMPANIES
PERPETUALLY HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR WELL HAD SAFETY. SO THE
POINT IS THIS THE EXIST THE THIS
TOOL IN THIS CONVERSATION AND
I'M SO DELIGHTED WERE HAVING IT
TODAY AND AGAIN I THANK ALL OF
YOU- THIS CONVERSATION WENT
DORMANT ON THE SHELF SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THERE HASN'T
BEEN ANY DISCUSSION. AND IF
THERE'S ANYTHING POSITIVE OUT OF
THIS OIL SPILL IT'S POSSIBLY TO
REIGNITE THIS CONVERSATION AND
TO REPLY BUT WE ALL KNOW WE ALL
SIT HERE AND WE ALL REALIZE
THESE OIL PLATFORMS NEED TO. BE
DECOMMISSIONED AND COME OUT M. I
WOULD JUST TELL YOU FROM MY
EXPERIENCE AND IN DOING THAT THE
BILL THAT WE HAD. IT WASN'T A
FIGHT. IT WASN'T TO BATTLE THE
OIL COMPANIES WANT A CLEAR PATH
TO COMPLIANCE THEY'RE OPERATING
AT A MANY CASES AT A LOSS BUT
IT'S CHEAPER TO OPERATE AT A
LOSS THAN IT IS TO FACE.
MILLIONS FOR DECOMMISSIONING.
THEY'RE LOOKING AND WAITING FOR
A CLEAR PATH THAN WE HAVE NOW
AND THAT'S THE CHALLENGE I WOULD
GIVE YOU THE LEGISLATORS- AND
YOU CAN DO IT AND SO. I THINK
THIS IS A SOLVABLE THING I THINK
THEY'RE STAKEHOLDERS WILLING TO
COME TO THE TABLE AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ANYWHERE YOU CAN IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER PRIME. AND I THINK WHAT
WE'LL TRY TO DO IS GO TO OUR-
REMOTE TESTIMONY AND GET
DIRECTOR BONHAM. ON THE LINE.
TAKE TO. YES BACK THE LETTER IN
ORDER. YES. HE'S HERE AND THERE
AND- LET ME KNOW IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO TURN IT OFF. WE
CAN WE CAN HEAR YOU AND WE DON'T
SEE THE VIDEO SAID BUT I THINK
AUDIO IS JUST FINE. SO WE CAN
CARRY. IT IS TRUE MY NAME IS JOE
FONG AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT. AND I
LIKE TO DO A COUPLE OF QUICK
INNINGS AND THEN TURNS TO MY
COLLEAGUE THE ADMINISTRATOR FOR
ARE ALL THIS IS BILL PREVENTION
AND RESPONSE MISTER ALAN. SO
HERE'S THE FIRST THING I LIKE TO.
CLARIFY WITH BUSINESS. FINALLY
WELLS BILLS YOU'LL IDOLS BILLS
BOTH BILLS ARE BAD. HURT US IN
SO MANY WAYS THAT WE CARE ABOUT.
FULL STOP. HEY ON THIS ASPECT.
OUR JOB WHO IS BILL'S STARTS IS
TO RESPOND. AND MANAGE IT IN THE
MOMENT. I LIKE TO DO IS JUST
THANK EACH OF YOU STARTING WITH
THIS YEAR. BUT LITERALLY ALMOST
EVERY PERSON ON THE PANEL TODAY
I'VE SPOKEN WITH SIGNIFICANTLY
OFFLINE ONE ON ONE OF THE COURSE
OF THE LAST MONTH AND A HALF.
UNFORTUNATELY I MET A FEW OF YOU
FOR THE FIRST TIME BECAUSE OF
THIS BILL. SOME OF YOU ARE KNOWN
FOR QUITE SOMETIME. AND I THINK
YOU SENDS TO. THE ORANGE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE THE CITY'S AND
COUNTY'S MAYOR KERR. YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE STATE SENATE.
ALL OF OUR NON PROFITS ALL THE
CITIZENS. IS SAN DIEGO ON OUR
INTERVIEW GOOD HI CAN WE HAVE
THE TACK IN THIS ROOM TO TURN
OFF THE VIDEO BECAUSE IT'S
MAKING. THE IDEA FUZZY. SORRY
DIRECTOR. LET'S TRY AGAIN YEAH
HERE'S MY THANK YOU- IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THIS WAS AN ALL HANDS
ON DECK EVERYBODY INVOLVED FOR
THE FIGHT THIS BILL. IT TOOK
TIME TO FIND OUR RHYTHM. BUT WE
HAVE COLLABORATED IN THIS BILL
ACROSS SO MANY LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. CITIES COUNTIES
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH STATE AND FEDERAL THAT
COLLECTIVE EFFORT IS ONE OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL PARTS OF THIS NO
RESPONSE IN MY OPINION. THE NEXT
THING I WANT IS JUST SKIP. ALL
THE REPEAT OF WHAT HAPPENED- AND
HOW IT HAPPENED. WE KNOW THESE
FACTS NOW. BACK IN THE BEGINNING
OF OCTOBER A PIPELINE OF.
DIRECTOR THE AUDIOS THE IDEA%
KEEPS DETERIORATING SO CAN WE
GET A PLAN C. I AM LOOKING AT
OUR OUR TECH ADMIN FOLKS OVER
THERE CAN WE PLEASE GET JUST
CALL IN NUMBER FOR. DIRECTOR
BONHAM AND OTHERS THE CALL INTO
THE HEARING AND NOT TRY TO DO
THE VIDEO LINK. THANK GOD YOU'RE
HERE TO. YOUR PEOPLE EIGHT
NUMBER JACK MESSAGE. OKAY AS WE
ARE GOING TO- DIRECTOR BY NUMBER
GOING TO HEAR FROM ONE
ADDITIONAL IN PERSON PANELIST
HOPEFULLY IN THE NEXT FIVE
MINUTES WE CAN COME UP WITH A
DIALING SOLUTION OTHERWISE I'M
GONNA CALL YOU FROM MY PHONE AND
PUT IT. ON THE SPEAKER. AS PLAN.
DATE ATTACK. FOR BEING WERE
BEING FLEXIBLE. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR WE WILL BE BACK TO YOU
IN FIVE MINUTES. WITH THAT.
MAYOR KIM CARR IS JOINING US
FROM THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH AMERICORPS WASN'T ON THE
FRONT LINE OF MUCH OF THIS
RESPONSE WERE GRATEFUL TO HAVE
YOU HERE TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING A LITTLE BIT
LATE WE HAD OUR STATE OF THE
CITY- THE ADDRESS THIS MORNING
FROM EIGHT AM TO TEN SO I CAME
STRAIGHT HERE- SO ASSEMBLY WOMAN
I JUST WANT TO. HOW MUCH TIME DO
I HAVE IF YOU WERE AT IF YOU
WANT TO DO SORT OF A THREE TO
FIVE MINUTES OKAY VIEW AND THEN
WE'LL HEAR FROM ALL THE
PANELISTS AND JUMP INTO SOME
MORE Q. AND A PERFECT SO I'LL
JUST GO IF IT'S OKAY WITH YOU
FROM THE BEGINNING OF WHEN WE
WERE NOTIFIED ABOUT THE OIL
SPILLS SO ON SATURDAY OCTOBER
SECOND WE- WE RECEIVED A
MESSAGE. THAT THE COAST GUARD
HAD PUT OUT A MESSAGE SAYING
THAT THERE WAS A POTENTIAL OIL
SPILL OFF THE SHORE OF COAST OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND SO WE
REALLY DIDN'T THINK IT WAS THAT
DRAMATIC AT THAT TIME IT WAS
SOMETHING TO JUST PUT ON THE
RADAR AND SO WE WERE MONITORING
IT BUT ALSO THAT DAY AS MOST OF
YOU PROBABLY KNOW WE WERE IN THE
MIDST OF OUR PACIFIC AIR SHOW
AND THAT DAY WE HAD ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION PEOPLE ON THE BEACH
AND HUNTINGTON BEACH TO ENJOY.
THE PACIFIC CARE SHOW SO WE WERE
MONITORING THIS OIL SPILL BUT
REALLY THE FOCUS WAS ON THE AIR
SHOW HROUGHOUT THE DAY WE
STARTED TO GET MORE MESSAGING
ABOUT THIS POTENTIAL OIL SPILL
AND WE STARTED GETTING SYSTEM
REALLY CONFLICTING MESSAGING
ABOUT IT SO AS THE DAY
PROGRESSED THE COAST GUARD HAD
TOLD US- THAT THIS OIL SPILL WAS
SIGNIFICANT HOWEVER IT WOULD NOT
BE REACHING OUR SHORE UNTIL
MONDAY OCTOBER FOURTH. SO AGAIN
WE WERE CONTINUING TO MONITOR
THIS AND AS WE STARTED TO GET
SOME FEEDBACK FROM VOTERS WHO
WERE OUT IN THE OCEAN- WATCHING
THE AIR SHOW WE STARTED TO
REALIZE THAT THIS WAS AS IN
GOING TO BE HEADING OUR SHORES.
ON MONDAY OCTOBER FOURTH. MORE
LIKELY IT WAS GOING TO BE
HITTING OUR SHORES THAT EVENING.
SO OUR FIRE DEPARTMENT MARINE
SERVICES- ALL OF OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS. GOT TOGETHER- AND
REALLY STARTED TO AN ACTOR OR
OIL SPILL RESPONSE PROGRAM- AND
WE HAVE ACTUALLY A- FULL. A
GIANT BINDER ON WHAT TO DO WHEN
THERE'S AN OIL SPILL. AND WE
DECIDED THAT MOMENT AT AROUND
TWO O'CLOCK IN THE AFTERNOON
THAT IF THE OIL DID START TO
APPROACH THE SHORES. WE WOULD
ENACT THAT PROCEDURE- ROUND FOUR
THIRTY THAT AFTERNOON. WE WERE
TOLD AGAIN THE OIL WOULD NOT BE
HITTING OUR SHORES AND TILL.
MONDAY OCTOBER FOURTH BUT THEY
WERE VOTERS OUT THERE SEEN
ACTUALLY THE OIL IS JUST A FEW
HUNDRED YARDS OFF YOUR COAST
RIGHT NOW. SO AT THAT MOMENT WE
DECIDED TO BE PROACTIVE AND
START TO LAY A LOT OF PROTECTIVE
BOOM AROUND OUR MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE AREAS.
LIKE THE TALBERT MARSH LIKE THE
BOLSA CHICA ECOLOGICAL RESERVE
SEVEN SENSITIVE SITES THROUGHOUT
THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON BEACH.
AND WE BY BY DOING THIS WE
REALLY FEEL AS THOUGH WE
AVERTED- A POTENTIAL ECOLOGICAL
DISASTER- BY NINE O'CLOCK THAT
EVENING. THERE WAS OIL ON THE
SHORES OF HUNTINGTON BEACH AGAIN
THIS WAS SATURDAY- AND THAT
EVENING WE DECIDED TO HOLD A
PRESS CONFERENCE AND LET OUR
RESIDENTS KNOW WHAT HAD HAPPENED
WITH THE LATEST INFORMATION THAT
WE HAD- SO. AGAIN IT WAS VERY
CHAOTIC I WOULD SAY FOR THOSE
FIRST THIRTY SIX HOURS. BUT THAT
SAID. THE NEXT DAY THE U. S.
COAST GUARD AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH. THEY CAME
TOGETHER AND AS- DIRECTOR BONHAM
SAID IT TRULY WAS AN ALL HANDS
ON DECK MOMENT- I AM GRATEFUL
WITH THE RESPONSE THAT THE COAST
GUARD IMPLEMENTED. WITHIN A
COUPLE OF DAYS WE LITERALLY HAVE
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE. ON OUR
SHORES CLEANING UP. TAR BALLS WE
HAD PEOPLE OUT AT THE TOP BURKE
MARCH SKIMMING OIL AND CLEANING
THAT AREA UP. AND BECAUSE OF ALL
OF THE PROTECTIVE MEASURES THAT
WE HAVE TAKEN AND BEING REALLY
PROACTIVE WE WERE ABLE TO AVERT
A LOT OF THE DAMAGE THAT
HAPPENED THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
HAPPEN. TO OUR WETLANDS- IT SO.
THROUGH ALL OF THIS PROCESS WE
WERE ABLE TO RE OPEN OUR BEACHES
WITHIN EIGHT DAYS AFTER THE
SPELL AND THIS WAS AFTER
EXTENSIVE WATER TESTING IN IT
AFTER YOU KNOW MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYTHING WAS CLEAN AND- THAT
IT WAS SAFE FOR OUR VISITORS OUR
SERVERS OUR COMMUNITY- BUT TO
GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF THE IMPACT
OF THIS. AS I MENTIONED ON
SATURDAY WE HAD THE AIR SHOW
WITH ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE OBVIOUSLY ON SUNDAY WE
HAD TO COUNSEL THAT. THAT WAS A
HUGE ECONOMIC IMPACT TO OUR
COMMUNITY THERE WERE RESTAURANTS
HOTELS- A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT HAD
GEARED UP FOR A MILLION PEOPLE
TO COME TO THE COMMUNITY SO. A
LOT OF THAT WAS. THERE WAS NO
WAY THAT YOU COULD RECOVER IF
YOU ADD BAR PURCHASED YOU KNOW A
TON OF FOOD AND A TON OF-
PROVISIONS FOR A MASSIVE CROWD
TO COME THAT JUST DOESN'T
HAPPEN. SO WE HAVE BEEN HEARING
FROM THE HOTELS THAT RECEIVED
CANCELLATIONS- FROM THE
RESTAURANTS THAT YOU KNOW HAD-
THAT THEY HAD TO EITHER SPOILER
GIVEAWAY- BUT AS A CITY. SO FAR
TO DATE WE HAVE SPENT OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ON THE
CLEAN UP THE FIRST WEEK ALONE WE
SPENT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND WE WERE AVERAGING
AROUND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER DAY. AND EXPENSES
TOWARD THE CLEAN UP- AND IN
ADDITION WE DID NOTICE A
SIGNIFICANT DROP OFF IN
RESERVATIONS AT THE HOTEL. WE
HAD TO CANCEL SEVERAL EVENTS WE
HAD SURF CONTESTS PLANNED WE
HAD- FOOD FESTIVALS PLANNED WE
HAD A LOT OF EVENTS THAT WE WERE
WE HAD TO CANCEL. BECAUSE OF THE
OIL SPILL- AND THEN. ALSO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THERE WAS A BIT OF
A- REPUTATION DAMAGETHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT. YOU KNOW THIS WAS A
INTERNATIONAL EVENT AND SO
PEOPLE WHEN THEY'RE THINKING
ABOUT WHERE TO PUT THEIR-
VACATION DOLLARS WHERE TO WHERE
THEY WANT TO GO FOR THEIR
CONVENTION. THEY TOOK A PAUSE
WHEN THINKING ABOUT GOING TO
ORANGE COUNTY OVERALL BECAUSE OF
THE OIL SPILL- I'M GRATEFUL
THOUGH TO SAY THAT WE- ARE
BLESSED WITH BEAUTIFUL WEATHER.
BEAUTIFUL BEACHES NEVER THE LESS
AND SO WE WILL RECOVER AND WE
WILL BE MORE RESILIENT AND
STRONGER THAN EVER. BUT AS YOU
KNOW OUR DIRECTOR BOTTOM SAID
THERE IS NO SUCH GOOD THING AS
AN OIL SPILL WE CONTINUE TO
LEARN WHAT WE COULD HAVE DONE
BETTER- AND I WOULD US IF THE
STATE LEGISLATORS WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT- OPPORTUNITIES TO GET
BETTER. WE REALLY FEEL THAT THE
RESPONSE THAT WE RECEIVED IS SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT DAYS IT REALLY IS
MINUTES IT'S HOURS THAT MAKE A
HUGE DIFFERENCE- YOU KNOW I LIKE
TO THINK THAT IF WE WOULD HAVE
HAD MAYBE A COUPLE OF MORE
HOURS. WE WOULD HAVE PREVENTED
SOME OF THE DAMAGE THAT HAPPENED
AT TALBERT MARCH THAT WE ARE
STILL DEALING WITH THE CLEAN UP.
I'M IF WE COULD HAVE HAD A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME MAYBE WE
COULD HAVE PREVENTED SOME OF
THAT OIL FROM. SEEPING INTO THAT
ECOLOGICALLY SENSITIVE AREA BUT
NEVER THE LESS I AS I SAID I
DON'T WANT TO- SAY ANYTHING
REALLY NEGATIVE ABOUT THE COAST
GUARD BECAUSE THEY WERE
FABULOUS- IT WAS JUST THAT
INITIAL. PERIOD WHERE THERE WAS
A LOT OF CONFUSION A LOT OF CAN
SIXTEEN AND FOR- IF THERE WAS
ONE THING THAT YOU KNOW WE'VE
HAD SOME TIME TO. KIND OF LOOK
BACK AND SAY YOU KNOW WHT COULD
WE HAVE DONE BETTER. AND TALKING
TO MY- FIRE CHIEF IN MY POLICE
CHIEF. WHAT WE CONSISTENTLY HERE
IS IF THE COAST GUARD COULD HAVE
NOTIFIED US IMMEDIATELY. RATHER
THAN THE PROCESS THAT THEY GO
THROUGH RIGHT NOW WHICH IS GOING
THROUGH A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
AGENCIES BEFORE. IT ACTUALLY
HITS THE AGENCY MOST AFFECTED BY
WHICH IS THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH MAYBE IF THAT COULD BE
MORE STREAMLINED AND SO THERE
WEREN'T SO MANY SILOS. OF THIS
DEPARTMENT DOES THIS THIS
DEPARTMENT DOES THAT AND THEN
ALSO- WE WERE BLESSED AND THAT
WE DID HAVE AN OIL SPILL
RESPONSE PLAN IN PLACE. AND IF I
HAD JUST ONE MINUTE A QUICK
STORY ABOUT THAT. WE WOULDN'T
HAVE HAD THE EQUIPMENT THAT WE
NEEDED TO TAKE CARE OF THIS OIL
SPILL HAD WE NOT HAD A BOAT THAT
SANK. THE YEAR BEFORE AND
HUNTINGTON HARBOUR AND THAT
CREATED A LITTLE BABY MANY OIL
SPILL IN HUNTINGTON HARBOUR IN
TWENTY TWENTY. SO OUR FIRE CHIEF
WAS LOOKING AT A OIL SPILL
RESPONSE PLAN AND SAID. HEY YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE MISSING SOME
EQUIPMENT HERE WE NEED THIS WE
NEED THAT. AND HE TOOK THE NEXT
YEAR APPLIED FOR GRANTS WAS ABLE
TO GET THINGS LIKE AN OIL SPILL
TRAILER SOME MORE PROTECTIVE
BOOM. AND WE LITERALLY JUST GOT
ALL OF THOSE ITEMS A FEW MONTHS
AGO. AND I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE IF
WE DDN'T HAVE THAT STUFF WITH
THIS OIL SPILL IN PLACE SO. IF
THERE'S A WAY THAT WE CAN
ENCOURAGE ALL OVER COASTAL
CITIES TO IMPLEMENTED OIL SPILL
RESPONSE PLAN AND HAVE THE TOOLS
THAT THEY NEED WHETHER IT'S YOU
KNOW SOME FUNDING FROM THE
STATE. SO THAT THEY CAN GET
THOSE GROUNDS- TO GET THAT
EQUIPMENT AND THEN ALSO IF
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
MORE OF A REGIONAL RESPONSE
BECAUSE- WE KNOW IN HUNTINGTON
BEACH WE HAVE A VERY LARGE
MARINE SAFETY. A GROUP A LARGE
FIRE DEPARTMENT BUT WE CAN
ALWAYS HELP OUT OUR NEIGHBORS I
SEAL BEACH. NEWPORT BEACH- AND
HAVE MORE OF A REGIONAL- A PRO
COACH IF NEED. BUT AGAIN I
COULDN'T BE MORE PROUD OF OUR
FIRE DEPARTMENT I COULDN'T BE
MORE PROUD OF- ALL OF OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS AND TO YOU. ASSEMBLY
WOMAN CUDDY PETRI NORRIS FOR
BEING THERE EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY- AND THEN TO ALL OF OUR NON
PROFITS LIKE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION THE BOLSA CHICA
WETLANDS THE BOLSA CHICA
CONSERVANCY. AND ALL OF THE
VOLUNTEERS WHO VOLUNTEERED NOT
JUST MONEY BUT THEIR TIME TO
HELP WITH THE CLEANUP SO. AS A
DIRECTOR BONTA SAID HE TRULY WAS
AN ALL HANDS ON DECK AND I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR EVERYBODY'S
HELP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MAYOR
CAR. UP WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
TAKE A TWO MINUTE RECESS THE
WEEKEND I. JUST FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO GET AUDIO CONNECTED WITH
DIRECTOR BONHAM. AT THIRTY
MINUTES WE WILL BE BACK.
ALL
RIGHT WE ARE BACK IN ACTION AND-
WE ARE GOING TO. DISPENSE WITH
THEIR FANCY TECHNOLOGY AND ADD
TO THE SOMEWHAT OLD SCHOOL TO-
DR BONHAM IS GOING TO BE JOINING
US. FOR MYSELF. ALL RIGHT AT
DIRECTOR BONHAM WE'VE GOT YOU ON
MY CELLPHONE AND- HOPEFULLY AT.
HOPEFULLY THE PUBLIC WILL BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOU AS YOU COME
THROUGH MY MICROPHONE. YEAH LOOK
SO I BETTER HAVE GOOD TESTIMONY
AFTER ALL THIS. SURE CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YES. OKAY HEY LET ME
JUST HERE'S WHAT I SAID IN THE
EARLIER EFFORTS- FIRST NO BILL
IS A GOOD SPELL THEY'RE ALL BAD
HEY HEARD ISN'T SO MANY WAYS WE
CARE ABOUT I ASSOCIATE MYSELF
WITH THEIR CARS EXPRESSION OF-
THE PAIN IN THE DIFFICULTY OF
THIS BILL AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
CHAIR I KNOW YOU FEEL THE SAME.
WE SPOKE OFTEN OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LAST MONTH. THE SECOND
THING I SAID WAS- I- HUGE THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE EVERYONE THERE
EVERYONE NOT THERE THAT HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN THIS BUT REALLY LET
ME TURN TO THE HEART OF IT. WE
CAN GET BETTER WE HAVE TO GET
BETTER THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF
COMING TO AN OVERSIGHT HEARING.
THAT'S THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF A
RELATIONSHIP WITH YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WE HAVE TO ADAPT. RESILIENCY IS
THE MEASURE OF LEARNING FROM
YOUR LESSONS. THIS HAPPENED
AFTER COSCO BUSAN IT HAPPENED
AFTER THE SANTA BARBARA SPILL
REFUGIO CALIFORNIA STRONG WE CAN
GET BETTER. SO HERE ARE SOME OF
THE THINGS I AM PERSONALLY
THINKING ABOUT AS AREAS OF. SO
THE FIRST EXAMPLE I THINK WE
NEED TO EXPLORE CAPACITY AT A
LOCAL LEVEL SO MAYOR CARNAGE
AND- BLOOD FOR THEM HAVING
SUBMITTED A GRANT AND RECEIVED A
QUICK MANNER THE RESPONSE AT
TALBERT MARSH MIGHT HAVE BEEN
MORE INJURED. THAT ACTUALLY IS A
GRANT PROGRAM I THINK OUR
DEPARTMENT RUNS TO US BURKE WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE THAT LOCAL RESPONSE
EQUIPMENT ABILITY BLOOM MOBILE
UNITS UP AND DOWN THE COAST AND
THE HUNTINGTON BEACH EXAMPLE OF
HOW THEY- FEEL GO FOR WAITED. ON
SATURDAY BY DEPLOYING AT TALBERT
MARSH IS A CASE STUDY WHY WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT CAPACITY OUR
CURRENT PROGRAM I THINK WAS IT
IS WITH ABOUT SIX PORTS. BUT
MAYBE WE NEED TO CONSIDER AT A
COUNTY LEVEL. A SECOND AREA OF
IMPROVEMENT AND MY MIND IS WE
NEED TO GO LOOK AT WHAT A CALL
BACK CONTINGENCY PLANS- THE
DOCUMENTS THAT THREE IDENTIFY
ALL THE SENSITIVE AREAS AND THE
STRATEGY. YES THIS BILL WHAT
HAPPENS. WHY OF THE THINGS
THAT'S US DOWN IN THE EARLY IS
WE SPENT A LOT OF THE SITE.
TRYING TO FIND THE NEXT PLACE
FOR THE INCIDENT COMMAND POST.
WE NEED GET BEYOND. AND
BASICALLY HAVE DONE OUR REAL
ESTATE DUE TO DILIGENCE BEFORE A
SPILL SO WE KNOW APPROPRIATE
PUBLIC VENUES WE CAN HOST THE
COMMAND. THAT ARE NOT FACILITIES
OWNED BY THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY I
THINK A RESPONSIBLE PARTY VENUE
CREATES CONFUSION IN THE PUBLIC.
AND UNDERCUTS TRUST. OTHER
EXAMPLES OF IMPROVEMENTS WE HAVE
THE WORLD'S BEST OILED WILDLIFE
CARE NETWORK AVAILABLE TO
RESPOND TO SPILLS. THAT IS A
REASON WHY WE GOT A SUCCESS IN
THIS BILL WE ACTIVATED THAT
NETWORK PROMPTLY IT ACTUALLY HAD
DISABILITIES AND EXPERTS IN THE
AREA. NEARBY WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO REPLICATE SOME
SIMILAR NETWORK. FOR OUR
CONSERVATION ENVIRONMENTAL NON
PROFITS UP AND DOWN THE COAST
SOME WAY TO PRE TRAIN REGULARLY
COMMUNICATE WITH AND STAYING
CLOSE CONTACT WITH OUR AFFILIATE
VOLUNTEERS SO WE'RE NOT DOING IT
IN THE CHAOTIC BEGINNING
MOMENTS. BUT THAT RESOURCES MORE
READILY AVAILABLE MORE READILY
DEPLOYABLE. WE TO IMPROVE IN
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL. YOU HEARD
FROM MISTER BROWN THAT. WE USE
OLD TECHNOLOGY I WOULD SUBMIT IN
RESPONSE BLAME WHETHER OLDER
NEWS HIGHLY EFFECTIVE IT'S WHAT
HELPS DEAL WITH ALBERT MARSH. WE
DID NOT USE THIS PERSON COMES
HELLO WE DON'T USE THEM IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S A LOT OF
REGULATION AROUND IT. BUT WHAT
WE HAVEN'T DONE YET IS CRACKED
THE TECHNOLOGY NOT ON MY TALK.
AS THE SHERIFF MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT IT'S NEAR IMPOSSIBLE TO
FIGURE OUT A DARK SHEEN IN THE
DARK OF NIGHT ON A DARK OCEAN
SURFACE BUT I GOTTA THINK. WITH
CALIFORNIA BEING A TECHNOLOGY
LEADER THERE MIGHT BE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS IN THAT SPACE
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES US PER TO
DO IT TECHNOLOGY WORKSHOP EVERY
TWO YEARS. IF WE FOLLOWED
CURRENT TIMELINE WE WOULD DO A
WORKSHOP I THINK IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WE NEED TO DO
WANTED TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND USE
THIS BILL AS THE FOCAL POINT FOR
THE TECHNOLOGY WORKSHOP WITH A
SPECIFIC FOCUS ON KIND OF NIGHT
TIME. TECHNOLOGY IN MY OPINION.
WE'RE IMPROVING IN THE MIDDLE
THIS BILL SIR. WAS ARE.
IDENTIFIED NONPROFIT LIAISE ALL
THROUGH THIS BILL THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE EVER DONE SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. ON THEIR OWN THEY CAME UP
WITH A TARBALL APPLICATION
PEOPLE COULD USE ON THEIR PHONES
AND WE'VE IMPLEMENTED THAT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS BILL HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY USEFUL ON OUR- LAST
AREA OF IMPROVEMENT I THINK THAT
I'M THINKING ABOUT. FISHERIES
CLOSURES AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AND- FORTY
FIVE SQUARE MILES STILL CLOSE
FOR COMMERCIAL AND RECREATIONAL
FISHING. I DON'T THINK WE CAN
SOLVE THE FISHERIES CALLING HER
DYNAMIC AND SPILLS BY BUILDING
ANOTHER LABORATORY SOMEWHERE.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS IT
TAKES ABOUT FOURTEEN DAYS TO THE
TECHNICAL ANALYSIS OF SAMPLES
FROM FISH WELL TO THE
HYDROCARBONS YOU'RE TESTING FOR.
BUT THIS BILL WE USE COMMERCIAL
FISHING TO HELP US COLLECTED
SAMPLES MAYBE THERE'S A WAY TO
USE COMMERCIAL FISHING MORE
COLLECTS SAMPLES FASTER MOVE THE
SAMPLES INTO PROCESSING SOONER
EVEN THOUGH WE MAY REMAIN WITH A
LABORATORY BOTTLE. THOSE ARE A
COUPLE OF IDEAS ABOUT HOW WE CAN
DO BETTER. AND I'LL JUST CONFIRM
FOR YOU WE KNOW HOW TO GET
BETTER WORKING WITH SOME OF THE
MEMBERS ON THE PANEL RIGHT THERE
WE LEARNED FROM THE REFUGIO
SPILL HERE'S WHAT WE DID IN THE
ORANGE COUNTY SAN DIEGO STILL.
THAT WE HAD NOT DONE IN SANTA
BARBARA. WE BROUGHT OUR TRIBAL
LIAISONS INTO THIS BILL MUCH
SOONER WE IDENTIFIED AN OFFICIAL
NONPROFIT ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP IS
A LIAISON POINT ACROSS AND INTO
THE- COMMUNICATION AND OUR
REGION EDUCATION DOT WITH
SURFRIDER. WE KEEP WITHIN ONE
WEEK ON THIS BILL MORE DEPLOYED
EXPERTS AND RESPOND EARNERS OVER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WHICH WAS
EXCEEDING THE MAXIMUM NUMBER WE
DID IN THE SANTA BARBARA WHICH
YOU JUST BILL WE HAD THAT WITHIN
SEVEN DAYS OF THE ORIGINAL. I'M
KIND OF STANDING UP TO THE
UNIFIED COMMAND THERE ARE OTHER
EXAMPLES OF WHAT WE CAN LEARN
FROM AND WE WILL LEARN FROM THIS
BILL WITH YOUR HELP AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
MANAGING THE TECHNOLOGY. ON THE
SOFTER. A WELL AND YOU DIRECTOR
BONHAM AFTER JOE US IN FOR YOUR
I JUST ENGAGE. ON BUT EMERGENCY
RESPONSE NOW AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AND LOOK TO LEARN FROM THIS
DISASTER AND DAD DO BETTER AS
WE- ARE AS WE GO FORWARD INTO
THE FUTURE. I'M WITH THAT I
THINK WHAT I'M GOING TO DO IS
OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
TO OUR PANELISTS. DIRECTOR
BOTTOM CAN YOU HEAR ME AS I'M
TALKING. ACT I'M THROUGH WHAT
WE'LL DO IS. ASK QUESTIONS IF
THE QUESTION IS DIRECTED TOWARDS
A DOCTOR BOND AND THEN WE'LL-
HOLD THEM UP TO THE MIKE. ALL
RIGHT SO. I AM GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REFI. AT THIRTY DIRECTOR OF
BOTTOM ARE YOU ABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE
BE DIRECTED CHIU ADMINISTRATOR
CALLING FROM OCTOBER OR DO WE
NEED TO ALSO GET HIM ON THE LINE.
LET'S TRY THAT KNOWING THAT MR
COHEN HAD A FANTASTIC
PRESENTATION AVAILABLE FOR YOU-
I THINK SUPPLY HIS SLIDES- AS A
SUBMISSION TO THOSE SPECIAL
COMMITTEE AFTERWARDS WITH YOUR
PERMISSION. AND HE'S ALSO ABLE
TO HEAR AND SEE AS WE GO THROUGH
THE CONVERSATION. AND I'LL
FIGURE OUT A LIAISON WITH HIM AS
WE GO THROUGH THIS OKAY
WONDERFUL I WILL ADD IT AT LEAST
ON MS DAVIS HAS A QUESTION. THAT
WILL BE DIRECTED TO OSTBERG I'M
GOING TO DIAL ADMINISTRATOR
CALLING INTO MY PHONE AS WELL
AND DAD. WHAT COLOR IS THAT WE
ALL RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AND YOU KNOW IF THE IF THE
DIRECTOR OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
CAN ANSWER YOU KNOW WHOEVER CAN
ANSWER I THINK IS FINE- AND
MICHAEL I HAVE A QUESTION
RELATED TO- YOU KNOW TO. THE
TIMELINE OF THE INCIDENT OF YOU
KNOW THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION'S PIPELINE AND
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS. SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION OFFICE THEY
ISSUED A CORRECTIVE ACTION ORDER
SAYING THE COMPANY RECEIVED A
PRESSURE DROP ALARM AT TWO
THIRTY AM. BUT THE PIPELINE
CARRYING CRUDE OIL WAS NOT SHUT.
DOWN UNTIL ABOUT SIX AM. ON
SATURDAY AND NOTED. THAT MY
OCCUR UNTIL NINE AM. THE STATE
LAW CALLS FOR IMMEDIATE
NOTIFICATION. IF THOSE TIMELINES
ARE ACCURATE. WOULD THAT BE
CONSIDERED IMMEDIATE
NOTIFICATION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
THINK WE'RE AND THE CHAIR SOUGHT
TO PATCH AND MINISTER CULLEN. I
DROPPED IN NEW. ARE YOU QUESTION
BUT LET ME ANSWER ANYWAY BECAUSE
I HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF WHAT
YOU'RE- ENQUIRING ABOUT. YOU
WERE ASKING TIMELINE QUESTIONS
THAT ARE INCREDIBLY RELEVANT
IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC BUT ARE
ALSO DIRECTLY IMPLICATED IN THE
PARALLEL- EVIDENTIARY GATHERING
AND INVESTIGATORY FRIENDS. I
AGREE WITH YOU THAT WALK WHEN
ONE LOOKS AT THE PUBLISHED
RECORD TWO GAMES THERE APPEAR TO
BE A VARIETY OF MOMENTS IN TIME.
ON FRIDAY EVENING INTO SUNDAY
WHERE THERE ARE POTENTIALLY
INCONSISTENCIES WE NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT NOT HI DAD. BUT
I'M ALSO LOOKING INTO WHO KNEW
WHAT WHEN BECAUSE SOME OF THESE
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS ON THE
FEDERAL FUNDS AND THE STATE
CRANCH RELATE TO POTENTIAL CIVIL
OR CRIMINAL LIABILITY. AND FROM
THERE I'M JUST NOT AT LIBERTY TO
COMMENT FURTHER. I AGREE WITH
MAYOR KERR. THAT THERE OUGHT TO
BE AWAY IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO
LOOK AT THE NATIONAL RESPONSE
CENTER PLATFORM LOOK AT THE
STATE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES WHICH ARE THE PRIMARY
MECHANISMS FOR PARTIES TO NOTIFY
GOVERNMENT. ABOUT A POTENTIAL
SPILL AND FIGURE OUT A WAY FOR A
MORE STREAMLINED STRUCTURE CAN
ALSO BE NOTIFIED LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL. DID ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH THANK
YOU- I HAD THE SAME QUESTION AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS SO ALL ALL
GO TO MY NEXT QUESTION WHICH WAS.
IT'S BEEN WIDELY REPORTED THAT
THE SPELL WAS LIKELY
PRECIPITATED BY AN ANCHOR
DRAGGING INCIDENT. HOW IS IT
POSSIBLE THE PIPELINES CONCRETE%
CASING COULD'VE BEEN CRACKED AND
THE PIPELINE DRUGS. SO
SIGNIFICANTLY WITHOUT TRIPPING
ANY SENSORS. SHARE I YOU KNOW IN
HINDSIGHT I'LL JUST CONTRAST-
UNLIKE THE- TALK ABOUT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION WHETHER IT'S MORE
APPROPRIATE TO ATTEND IN PERSON
I KNOW- THIS IS EXTREMELY
COMPLICATED BUT I COULD NOT HEAR
THE IS SOMEONE. YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH I IS
ASKING HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT I
COULD BE THE CAUSE OF THE
RUPTURE WITH AN ANCHOR STRIKE
THAT HAS BEEN CONFIRMED- THOUGH
THE EXACT TIMING OF THE STRIKE
IS STILL UNDER INVESTIGATION.
HER QUESTION IS HOW IS IT
POSSIBLE THAT THAT COULD HAVE
RUPTURED THE CONCRETE CASING. OF
THE- SO HIGHER ACTION SO
CORRECTION ON THE QUESTION CAN
YOU HEAR ME DIRECTOR BOTTOM. SO
I AM NOT NOR IS OUR DEPARTMENT
OR OSCAR THE PIPELINE
JURISDICTION EXPERT MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PIPE IS
VERY SIMILAR TO YOURS AND OUTER
CASING OF CONCRETE AND INNER
KIND OF CASING OF METAL-
APPROXIMATE THIRTEEN AND CHORES
ON A CRACK- ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND
FEET OF THE PIPELINE WAS MOVED
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIVE SHE
ALSO CENTER. I THINK THAT WE ARE
IN THE MIDDLE OF- YOU KNOW THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY BEING SUBJECT
TO A FEDERAL CORRECTIVE ORDER.
THE PIPELINE AND HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS SAFETY ADMINISTRATION-
THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY IS IN THE
MIDDLE OF. YOU KNOW. KEELING
WITH HOW TO REMOVE THAT SECTION
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF OUR
WARDENS MONITORING THE CHAIN OF
CUSTODY THIS IS EVIDENCE FOR YOU
KNOW POTENTIAL CRIMINAL AND
CIVIL LIABILITY I COULDN'T TELL
YOU HOW AND WHY THE PIPE ITSELF-
YOU KNOW SUFFERED A POTENTIAL
STRIKE OR WIDE STRESSED THAT WAY
THAT'S REALLY A QUESTION
PROGRAMS ARE. OR ARE STATE FARM
MARSHALL IS A PIPELINE EXPERT.
AND WE WILL BE AT WE WILL BE
HEARING FROM THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL AT IN OUR SECOND PANEL
YES BUT MY QUESTION WAS NOT SO
MUCH ABOUT THE MOVEMENT AND THE
CAUSALITY UNDERSTAND THAT'S
UNDER INVESTIGATION. BUT WHY
WERE THERE NO SENSORS THAT
INDICATED THAT THERE WAS SMOKE.
I CAN- ASSEMBLY MEMBER. A LOT OF
SENSORS OR ARE. NOT SUFFICIENT
MONITORING RELATIVE TO THE
PIPELINE OR QUESTIONS BETTER
TAKEN TO THEM SO OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE INTERIOR
BUREAU OF SAFETY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ENFORCEMENT. AGAIN
A LARGE PART OF THIS DYNAMIC IS%
FEDERAL JURISDICTION IN FEDERAL
WATERS. PIPELINE I KNOW THAT'S A
FRUSTRATING RESPONSE FROM US.
BUT FOR OUR DEPARTMENT AND ALSO
PER VIEW IS REALLY THRILLING
TRIP PRACTICING FOR RESPONSE AND
THEN DEALING WITH AN UPSET IN
THE MOMENT. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
BUT QUESTIONS FROM OTHER MEMBERS
EITHER FOR THE DOCTOR FOR ANYONE
ELSE AT MR BLAME. HELLO DIRECTOR
BOTTOM IT'S A GOOD TO HEAR YOUR
VOICE AGAIN EVEN IF WE CAN'T SEE
YOU- I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- R. IS THERE
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE TODAY- THAT
WOULD ALLOW BETTER RESPONSE IN
THE DARK. I HAVE NOT HEARD ANY
BUT I CONFESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I'M NOT THAT BEST TECHNOLOGY
EXPERT I AM. REPORTER THE MAIN
KIND OF THE LACK OF RADAR IN
THIS SPACE IT WAS A CONVERSATION
IN THIS SENATE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE. THIS IS WHY I
RECOMMENDED I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATOR ALWAYS SPORTS WE
DO. THE REQUIRED TECHNOLOGY
WORKSHOP A YEAR SOONER THAN WE
WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE AND WE MAKE
THIS NIGHT TIME ISSUE A SPECIFIC
FOCUS AND I WOULD TAKE IT A STEP
FURTHER. ONE OF THE AREAS OF
IMPROVEMENT QUESTIONING ALSO
COMING OUT OF THIS BILL WOULD BE
A CONVENING WITH OUR EXPERTS IN
OUR UNIVERSITY SPACE. SO WE HAVE
A LOT OF FOLKS WHO WHO ARE
EXPERTS USE UC SANTA BARBARA
SCRIPTS INSTITUTE UC SAN DIEGO.
I HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN
WRAPPING AND OTHER IMAGERY
TECHNOLOGY AND I THINK WE OUGHT
TO GO TO SOLICIT THEIR FEEDBACK
AS WELL NOT JUST INDUSTRIES.
THAT RAISES AN INTERESTING
QUESTION- WE AT LAST YEAR FUNDED
A- A WILDFIRE RESPONSE INSTITUTE
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DO WE HAVE- ANY KIND OF FORMAL
COORDINATED EFFORT AMONGST- ANY
OF OUR- A PUBLIC- AT A HIGHER
READ SEGMENTS ON THE ISSUE OF
OIL SPILLS. YES AND A VARIETY OF
WAYS BUT PROBABLY NOT ONE AND
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON LIKE
SOME OF THIS TECHNOLOGY RADAR.
WITH OUR UNIVERSITIES WE- HAVE
TECHNICAL WORKING GROUPS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE- MISTER BROWN B.
EARLIER WITNESS MENTIONED HIS
PARTICIPATION IN THE LA LONG
BEACH FOR OSCAR TECHNICAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. WE ALSO HAVE
IS YOU KNOW A FORMAL FONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE OLD
WILDLIFE CARE NETWORK- FROM THE
WILDLIFE RESPONSE SPACE. I THINK
WE NEED TO LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE
EXISTING MODELS AND ASK AND
ANSWER WHETHER WE SHOULD
REPLICATE SOMETHING SIMILAR. IN
THE NONPROFIT WORLD IN THE
UNIVERSITY WORLD. AND WHETHER
THOSE TO NOON- KIND OF MODELS
COULD HELP US TO BETTER IN
SCHOOLS. THANK YOU AND HAVE A
DIRECTOR BOTH YOU AND- MAYOR
KERR. SPOKE ABOUT THE. OIL SPILL
RESPONSE PLANS AND- AFTER AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL CITIES AND COUNTIES
AND I- TOOK ADVANTAGE OF FOR A
NOT DURING THIS MEETING TO SEND
A TEXT TO SOMEBODY I KNOW- BACK
FROM- MY MAYORAL DAYS- IN IN
SANTA MONICA AND THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT- TO SEE IF SANTA
MONICA HAS AN ORAL RESPONSE PLAN
THAT IT BEING A- COASTAL CITY
AND THE ANSWER IS NO- SO- I
THINK IT WOULD BE- WHO BEST TO-
TALK ABOUT THIS MORE AS- OUR
BUDGET PROCESS MOVES FORWARD- I
DO WANT TO- SAY THAT- I DON'T
THINK THE STATE SHOULD BE PAYING
FOR THIS I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE FUNDED
BY THE OIL INDUSTRY- MUCH AS WE
DO WITH OTHER- CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE. WITH RESPECT TO- OIL
DRILLING- BUT- DO WE HAVE A
SENSE OF HOW MANY CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE COASTAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES HAVE FAR RESPONSE PLANS.
AND EQUIPMENT. I DON'T NEARLY
ALL OF MY HEAD I CAN DEFINITELY
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR OFFICE IN
THE CHAIR'S OFFICE WITH THAT
INFORMATION- WE DO HAVE EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE PRIMARILY
STRUCTURED. THROUGH THE MAJOR
PORTS ALONG THE COAST AND I
THINK WE OUGHTA GO LOOK AT AND
CONSIDER WHETHER WE NEED TO TAKE
OUR EXISTING MODEL WITH
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND SEE IF IT'S
APPLICABLE AT THE CITY LEVEL AS
WELL. AND I'D LIKE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON THE EXACT NUMBERS OF
THE GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
DO YOU I HAVE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION RELATED TO. THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE ARE DEPLOYING
TO A RESPONSE TO BEST PREVENT
AND RESPOND TO SPELL SO. AND AS
WITH MISTER BROWN POINTED OUT
THAT OSTBERG. IT HAS BEEN WHAT
THIRTY ONE YEARS SINCE OCTOBER
WAS APPROVED- SUIT I GUESS MY
QUESTION DIRECTOR FOR YOU IS TO
WHAT EXTENT HAVE OUR STATE AND
ENTITIES FORCE THE INDUSTRY TO
DEVELOP AND DEPLOY THE
TECHNOLOGY TRAINING PROCEDURES
MANPOWER LEVELS OPERATIONAL
METHODS THAT MEET. THE
TECHNOLOGY FORCING REQUIREMENTS
OF THE ACT AND FIVE WHAT MORE
SHOULD WE BE DOING AS POLICY
MAKERS TO ENSURE THAT THE-
TECHNOLOGY FORCING LANGUAGE
WHICH IS ACTUALLY QUITE POWERFUL
IS BEING FULLY UTILIZED TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE BRINGING THE
BEST THAT WERE REGULARLY
UPDATING BEST PRACTICES AND
BRINGING THOSE TO BEAR. BOTH IN
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE. SO
COUPLE THINGS CHAIRMAN AND- NO
JOKE HERE THIS IS A QUESTION THE
ADMINISTRATOR AND I WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT AND HE- ACTUALLY.
IT IS ABLE TO IDENTIFIED
SPECIFIC MOMENTS AND
IMPROVEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
OVER THE- LAST DECADES. SO I
DON'T KNOW THE ABILITY TO TOUCH
TO HIM MORE I CAN ACTUALLY MAKE
A LIFELINE CALL TO HIM. WHAT HAS
HAPPENED MOST RECENTLY NOT IN
TECHNOLOGY IS ALSO ARE ALSO
SWEET AND IMPROVEMENTS THE
LEGISLATURE ANOTHER'S. THE
FINDINGS STRUCTURE PROSPER HAS
BEEN CHANGED RECENTLY WHICH ALSO
LEADERSHIP TO ALLOW US TO ENSURE
CONTINUED CAPACITY. WE'VE ALSO
SEEN SOME CHANGES- IN THE DECADE
UP IN DIRECTOR AROUND- INSURANCE
ANOTHER BUT FISCAL REQUIREMENTS
ON INDUSTRY WE'VE SEEN SOME
CHANGES FOR- NOTIFICATION KIND
OF DYNAMICS SO I THINK AT LEAST
IN MY TENURE THE LAST DECADE I
COULD POINT YOU TO SOME
IMPROVEMENTS. ON THE TECHNOLOGY
SPACE- I HEAR YOU I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE IS CORRECT TO PUSH
US TO EMBRACE THE FORCEFULNESS
OF THAT STATUTORY LANGUAGE AND
DO BETTER PUSHING INDUSTRY. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT MEASURE COLIN
COLIN IS THE ONE WITH THE BEST
EXAMPLES OF THE PLACES WE HAVE
PUSHED THEM ON TECHNOLOGY. OKAY
LET'S DO THIS LET'S ADD DIRECTOR
CAN YOU TRY I'M GONNA TURN AND
ASK A QUESTION UNRELATED TO THIS
OF THE CAPTAIN WEILAND- ON IT
WHILE SOME DOING NOT CAN YOU TRY
TO GET. I ADMINISTRATOR CULLEN
ON THIS LINE SO THAT HE CAN.
BONDS BOND BUT THAT QUESTION AND
I THINK THERE WITH SOME OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WERE ADMINISTRATOR COLIN
IS BEST POSITIONED TO RESPOND
OKAY AND- WE'RE TRULY A FAIL
SAFE IF. YOU'RE ON YOUR PHONE
THAT'S BECAUSE I MADE THE
MISTAKE OKAY THEN I'LL CALL IT
MISTER CONKLING AND GET A SMALL
PATCH THE CURRENT DOWN TO GET
THANK YOU- RIGHT. WHILE WE'RE
WORKING ON ON THAT- CAPTAIN WELL
AND- I WOULD. I. ABOUT IT OVER
THE PHONE IF YOU HEAR OUR- HELLO.
HELLO CURRENT. I'M GONNA MIDDLE.
MISTER CULLEN. SURE
ADMINISTRATOR CALLING CAN YOU
HEAR ME. I CAN'T GET HIM. AT YES
WE WITH THAT SORRY CHECK WE'VE
GOT FIVE MINUTES LATER CULLEN
COMING THROUGH THE- I HAVE
CAUGHT UP THERE SO- WE ARE GOING
TO HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO HEAR
FROM HIM. ADMINISTRATOR COLIN
ARE YOU ABLE TO RESPOND TO MY
EARLIER QUESTION REGARDING THE
FIVE. QUITE STRONG TECHNOLOGY
FOR THE LANGUAGE THAT IS PART OF
OSTBERG HOW HAVE WE UTILIZE THAT
AND HOW CAN WE AS POLICYMAKERS-
ENSURE THAT WE ARE. USING NOT
MORE FORCEFULLY MOVING FORWARD.
ABSOLUTELY YOU HAVE. HOW
CALENDAR OVERSTOCKS YES- THANKS
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ABOUT- TECHNOLOGY AND
ADDED I REALLY- BY THE DIRECTOR
OF IN OUR ONLY STATUTE WE ARE
REQUIRED TO EVALUATE BEST
ACHIEVABLE TECHNOLOGY FOR CELL
RESPONSE IN WALTER BROWN TALKED
ABOUT PERHAPS ANYWAY AUDIENCE
RECORD BONTA SAID IT YES BUT WHO
IS VERY ACTIVE WHICH IS- WE DO
COHOST- EVERY TWO YEARS. AT SOME
POINT OUT A SINGLE RESPONSE
TECHNOLOGY WORKSHOP YOU KNOW WE
ARE PLANNING NOW IN LIGHT OF
THIS STILL TO HOLD ONE PERHAPS
IN THE FIRST QUARTER OF CALENDAR
TWENTY TWO. WITH ANY PARTICULAR
NOT TO DETECTION ESPECIALLY AT
NIGHT- I'LL SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
TO- CONTAINMENT AND CLEANUP
TECHNOLOGIES AND WIND UP MISTER
BLOOM WAS- A US SOLDIER BROWN
HOPING OTHERS SEEING OUR STATE
WIDE PRESENCE- ARE BEYOND THE
COAST ADDING TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN- TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
WATERS WE REALLY LOOK AT IT AS
AN EXAMPLE ABU CYNICALLY USES
WITH MOVING WATERS THAT WOULD
ALLOW WATER TO WONDERFUL WE
STILL SLOW BUT CAPTURING THE OIL
SERVICE NOTICES TECHNOLOGY THAT
IS IMMERSED IN THE LAST. DECADE
OR SO- THERE'S A COMPETITION I
DON'T DISABILITY HOLLOWS CALL
THE AS FAR AS YOU KNOW THAT WE
WILL SEE IF YEARS AGO IT WAS A
COMPANY THAT ONE MILLION DOLLAR
PRIZE FOR IMPROVING THE DISK ARE
SKIMMERS THAT ARE NOW GOING TO
BE EMPLOYED I MANY CLEAN
OFFICIALS SAW PERHAPS LARGE AND-
BOB- SORT OF RESPONSE OR ALL
PAYER IN A FOR WEEK. GOKONGWEI
ALL OF THAT IN ABOUT CONSIDER
OIL ON INITIATIVES OF THE WATER
GAS NEW TECH SO WE'RE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT ON WATER ON SHORE
TECHNOLOGIES I THINK OF IT
OPPORTUNITY. GOING FORWARD IT'S
GOING TO BE. WE OPPORTUNITY FOR
US AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE LAST WEEK BUT I HAVE
TO GET. AND I THINK- CERTAINLY
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE IS A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY HERE I
THINK I'M GONNA CERTAINLY FOR ME
FOR THE GENERAL PUBLIC ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT IT SEEMS LIKE
MOST BAFFLING. ABOUT THIS IS
THAT NOW WE'RE LIVING IN A WORLD
WHERE WE'RE SENDING. WHAT WE'RE
SENDING PEOPLE TO MARS YET WE
ARE UNABLE TO INSPECT AN OIL
SLICK. UNTIL FIRST LIGHT- I
THINK THAT KIND OF BOGGLES.
PEOPLE'S MINE. AND FIVE. I THINK
THAT THERE IS A HUGE OPPORTUNITY
FOR US IS CALIFORNIA WITH
ENGAGEMENT WITH ART. I COULD I
MAKE AN NONPROFIT COMMUNITY AS
PART OF IT TO DEVELOP NEW AND
MORE INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT WERE ABLE TO RESPOND
MORE SWIFTLY AND MORE ROBUSTLY.
I'M ARE THERE OTHER FOR MR
CULLEN BEFORE WE- MOVE ON RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES THANK YOU
MR COHEN JUST A QUICK QUESTION-
WHAT CAN YOU- SUGGEST OTHER
STATES DO THAT WE DON'T DO WHEN
IT COMES TO OIL SPILLS SUCH AS
GULF COAST STATES AND OIL
PRODUCTIONS. THAT THE QUESTION
I'D LIKE TO TAKE OFF FLYING ON
THE M. IN AND FOR EXT ON WE HELP
CERTAIN. ARE A THE CUTTING- YOU
KNOW AND HE- NOT JUST WITHIN THE
STATES FOR WORLDWIDE OUR OIL
SOLD. PROGRAMS AND SO THAT WOULD
BE AN INTERNATIONAL AREA THAT WE
DO LAGGED AND ACCOUNTS UP
PERCENT. OF OUR OIL SPILL
REPORTS IN THE ARMENIAN
ABANDONED OR WITH. THAT ARE
ALONG THE COAST IN THE- IN ORDER
TO HELP RIVER DELTA- THAT WE
WERE NEED TO GET A POP GRIP ON
THOSE AS A CITY IN THE K. AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF RESPONSES- EURO TO
THOSE WITH. ARE PARTNERS. WITH A
SEPARATE THREAT. NINE QUESTION
BEFORE DIRECTOR AND WHEN IT'S
TIME. I HAVE. A GOOD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. I THINK. DR BOND- IF THE
OIL COME FOR NOT RESPONSE FOR
THE OIL LEAK. AT THE CONCLUSION
THIS AND- WARILLA AT THE OIL
COMPLETELY AS US. ARE THERE NOT-
IN. CHRIS ASSOCIATED WITH TANKER
SHIPS BRINGING AN OIL FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES WHOSE STANDARDS ARE
NOT THE EQUIVALENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA- WHAT ABOUT THE JOB
LOSSES AN INCREASE IN THE COST
FOR EVERYONE. THANK YOU. IT WAS
A INCOME I AM BUT I THINK YOU'RE
ASKING- WHY TABLE RISING
INDUSTRY AND WE NEED THEM IN
RESPONSE AND HOW DO YOU CONSIDER
THE BROADER ECONOMIC DYNAMICS.
LOOK I'M NOT HERE TO INSPECT
POLICY FLAG. KILLER ARENA. WE'RE
CAST WITH DEALING WITH THE REST-
THAT'S HAPPENING FIGHTING THIS
BILL AND THEN LEARNING DURING
THE NEXT TIME BUT I WILL YOU.
DONATION IS MADE CAL LEADER ON
THAT FOR TO FACE OUT THE OF FUEL
FOR THE CARD CRISIS AND PROTECT
EARNED BY. THAT'S GOT TO HAPPEN
IN THE CON OF- PROTECTING IN.
AND POSE THE- I THINK MAYOR- CAN
SPEAKER ELOQUENTLY THE BALLOT OF.
ALONG THE COAST AS WELL AS YEAR
KNOW AND I THINK HE IS MANY OF
THE- THAT APOLLO. STROLLER FIND
BY. NOT JOB TO DATE. COMMENT ON
WHY TO DO WITH AN INDUSTRY THINK
WHEN WE THIS. WHEN WE PRODUCTION.
WE WILL ALWAYS HAVE TO RISKS BUT
ALL KNOWS BILL A GOOD IT ARTS IS
IN MANY WAYS I'M NOT YOU TO BE
FOR. HIGHLIGHTED IN THE MOMENT
LEARN FROM EXPERIENCE AND. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE IT IS ONE THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I DO AGREE WE
NEED REALLY FOR ON UPGRADING
TECH. THANK YOU FOR. AND I WOULD
ISN'T BAD AS A MEMBER ON I DO
EXT AS HAS A- RICH ROBUST DEATH.
AND DEBATE- AS PART OF OUR
SUBSEQUENT HEARING. ON YOU MADE
THE POINT ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT THAT OFFSHORE DRILLING.
HAS FOR THE STATE. I WOULD
SIMPLY POINT OUT THAT OUR
OFFSHORE DRILLING OFF THE COAST
OF CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTS FOR. ONE
THIRD. ONE THIRD OF ONE PERCENT.
OF THE UNITED STATES OIL
PRODUCTION. WHEN YOU COMPARE
LEAVING ASIDE THE O'CLOCK
LOGICAL BRISK LEADING IT LEAVING
ASIDE THE DAMAGE THAT IT'S DOING
TO OUR ENVIRONMENT. WHEN YOU
SIMPLY COMPARE THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF THE ACT. WITH THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF SHUTTING DOWN
OUR COASTAL ECONOMY IN ORANGE
COUNTY OR IN SAN DIEGO ORANGE
SANTA BARBARA OR SANTA MONICA.
FOR WEEKS OR MONTHS. IT REALLY
IS INFINITESIMALLY SMALL AND SO
THAT IS I THINK WHY I WOULD
AGREE. WITH THE POINT MISTER
BROWN MADE WHICH IS THAT THERE
REALLY IS AN OPPORTUNITY. FOR US
TO WORK AND DEVELOP I THINK A
COLLABORATIVE TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY. AND TO DEVELOP
A SOLUTION SO THAT WE CAN. THAT
WE CAN AND AFTER DRILLING OFF
THE COAST AND I. ABSOLUTELY WANT
OUR COMMITTEE TO S. ENGAGE IN
THAT CONVERSATION AND
DISCUSSION- BUT- I DON'T WANT
THAT TO BE THE FOCUS OF TODAY'S
HEARING I WANT THAT I WANT THE
FOCUS OF TODAY'S HEARING. TO BE
WHAT ARE THE STEPS THAT WE NEED
TO TAKE BETWEEN NOW AND JANUARY.
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE INTRODUCING.
LEGISLATIVE AND PROPOSALS
ADDRESS. SHORT TERM AND- WHEN WE
RECONVENE THIS COMMITTEE I WANT
US TO. BE VERY FOCUSED ON. A
PLAN TO PHASE OUT. DRILLING ON
THE COAST TO. WITH THAT I'VE GOT
ONE QUESTION FOR OUR CAPTAIN
WELLAND AT CAPTAIN I WANT TO
PICK UP ON AT APPOINT THAT MAYOR
KERR MADE REGARDING I AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STREAMLINE
COMMUNICATIONS IN ORDER TO. FIVE
IMPROVE COORDINATION
PARTICULARLY IN KIND OF THOSE
THOSE EARLIEST HOURS I WOULD
JUST LOVE TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AND REFLECTIONS ON
THAT AND IF THERE ARE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE. SALINAS ARE. OF THE IN
POINT OUT THAT THE FRIDAY I WAS
AT THE- SHOW MY WORKING AT THE
COMMAND POST AND THEN- GIVEN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MY SERGEANTS TO
WORK MY POSITION. BECAUSE I SAID
NOTHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN ON
SATURDAY SO GO AHEAD AND- THE
TAKE PETS A SPOT AND THEN OF
COURSE IT DID BUT- WE WERE IN
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE CITY
HUNTINGTON BEACH BALL FIRED
POLICE AT THAT COMMAND POST IN
THE U. S. COAST GUARD WAS THERE
AS WELL. FOR THE AIR SHOW IN SO
THAT'S WHERE WE INITIALLY- GOT
THE INFORMATION FROM WAS FROM
THE COAST GUARD OFFICIAL AT THAT
AT THE AIR SHOW- IT IS GOING
FORWARD WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IS SOME KIND OF- COASTAL C. AND
COUNTY. OIL SPILL REPORTING
SYSTEM WHERE ANY COASTAL CITY OR-COUNTY COULD BE PART OF THAT
SYSTEM. AND IN INTER INFORMATION
WHEN THEY HAVE A HAZMAT NOT JUST
OIL BUT ANY ANY LARGE BILL.
COULD BE ENTERED INTO THAT
SYSTEM WILL AUTOMATICALLY NOTIFY
ALL THESE OTHER CITIES AND
COUNTIES ALONG THE COASTLINE. IN
THE END SO THAT WE EACH OF THOSE
CITIES AND COUNTIES CAN
DETERMINE WHAT RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO DEPLOY AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. BECAUSE THE IMMIGRANT
WITH THE AMERICA- IS MUCH
INFORMATION AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
IS BETTER FOR- FOR A BETTER
RESPONSE AND FASTER RECOVERY.
THE ANY SITUATION IN THE IT
WITHIN THAT SYSTEM THE COAST
GUARD ANY. ANY OIL COMPANY
OPERATING WITHIN- OUR WATERS
CAN- REPORT THAT IN THAT THE-
BED OR ANY TYPE OF OIL SPILL
FROM THE SHIP LARGER THAN SAY A
HUNDRED FEET MEANING CARGO
SHIPS. OIL TANKERS AND SUCH IN A
ANY OR PLATFORMS PIPELINES INTO
THE SYSTEM. THAT WILL BE MY
RECOMMENDATION BUT OTHERWISE I
THINK- AT IS A PRACTICAL
STANDPOINT WE DID WE WORKED AS
AS QUICKLY. AND EXPEDITIOUSLY AS
POSSIBLE WITH THE EVERY SITTING
COUNTY OFFICIAL LIKE I SAID WE
MADE AS MANY NOTIFICATIONS EARLY
ON. AS POSSIBLE AS WE COULD- BUT
I THINK- IT YOU KNOW DO THEY
HAVE AN OFFICIAL MESSAGE. FROM
FROM- OF THE STATE A WHEN THINGS
LIKE THAT HAPPEN THAT THAT WOULD
BE MORE HELPFUL. THANK YOU
CAPTAIN. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHEN AND THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS AND I THINK WE WILL BE
GOING TO WRAP UP THIS PANELING
AND TRANSITION. THANK YOU IF I
CAN FOLLOW UP WITH THAT
COMMENTED SHE MADE- I DO I WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THAT ALSO
INCLUDES THE STATE AS PART OF
NOTIFICATION RIGHT AND WHICH
MEANS THE STATE LEGISLATIVE BODY
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY DIDN'T GET
ANYTHING. I ACTUALLY GOT IT FROM
THE CITY AND THANK GOODNESS THAT
CITY HUNTER BEACH WAS ON TOP OF
IT BUT AS THE INFORMATION
IMMEDIATELY TO THE MEMBERS AND I
ACTUALLY GOT YOU KNOW A DASH A
TEXT MESSAGE FROM THE MAYOR
HERSELF AND EXEDRA. THAT WAS
VERY HELPFUL TO US BUT YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT THERE NEED TO BE
COORDINATION NOT JUST COUNTY
CITY BUT ALSO STATE THESE
NOTIFICATION IN NOTIFICATION WE
GET A LOT. OF FROM WHAT WERE WE
ARE IN OUR POSITION WE GET A LOT
OF OCCASION. DOESN'T MEAN THAT
EVERY NOTIFICATION WE GET WE
SENT IT OUT TO THE PUBLIC WE ARE
VERY MINDFUL WHAT IS SET DOWN
WITH NOT SIMPLE MODIFICATION SAY
HEY WE HEARD OF THIS AND WE
THINK THIS IS HAPPENING WE DON'T
KNOW YET I IN THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL I WAS AT THE AIR SHOW.
ON SATURDAY ALL DAY. AND PEOPLE
COMING UP TO MIMIC WHAT DO YOU
TALK ABOUT MINISTERS IN THERE SO
WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT IF THE
WHERE. A. I. AND IT DIDN'T EVEN
LIKE IT WAS MORE JUST LIKE
COUPLE PEOPLE WALKING BY SAY HEY
DID YOU HEAR THIS A. LOT I
HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING. AND
NIGEL LATER THE- EVENING EARLY
EVENING. EARLY AFTERNOON AS WELL
WE HEARD THE CITY. SO ADDING IN
ANY KIND OF NOTIFICATION PROCESS
IT NEEDS TO GO TO A LOT OF IN
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT AGENCIES. AND
NOT JUST CITY AND COUNTY- BUT I
DO HAVE TO. GIVE KUDOS TO THE TO
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND
ALSO TO THE CITY. FOR YOUR-
SPEEDY. GETTING INFORMATION OUT
TO ALL OF US AND BREAK THEIR AT
THAT MOMENT IMMEDIATELY AND SO
WE DO APPRECIATE THAT- I'VE GOT
A COUPLE OTHER QUESTIONS MADAM
CHAIR- I'M- MR POLLAN- WOULD
WHAT WAS BOOKED EARLY BEFORE YOU
GOT ON WAS ABOUT- THE CITY OF
HUNDRED BEACH HAS A BOOKLET A
BINDER THAT SHOWS HOW TO DEAL
WITH OIL SPILL AND- J. BLOOM
JUST CONTACTED ONE OF HIS
CLOSEST CITY AND THEY SAID THEY
DON'T HAVE SOMETHING. MY
QUESTION FOR YOU IS FOR THE
STATE SIDE BECAUSE WE HAVE-
COASTAL BEACHES FROM STATE NOT
JUST THE CITY IN MY DISTRICT WE
HAVE BOTH A CHICA STATE BEACH
EDAD MY FORMER SENATE SEAT WE
HAD THE HUNTER BEACH STATE BEACH
AS WELL. SO DO WE AS A STATE
HAVE ANY BOOKLET. THAT TALKS
ABOUT HOW WE COORDINATE WITH
CITIES AND HOW WE MOVE ABOUT
CITIES AND LOCAL- YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF RESPONSE TO AN OIL
SPILL. THANK YOU- PRESIDENT BOND
FROM EVERY MISSTEP ADMINISTRATOR
THE MISTER COLON OKAY. HELLO
OKAY I'M I'M I'M WITH YOU SO-
AS- A DIRECTOR BONTA MEASURE
EARLIER TOMORROW YEAH YOU
REFERENCE THE- AREA CONTINUES
PLANS RECALL EIGHTY WERE ARE
PLAN THAT THE COAST CALIFORNIA
WERE WORKING ON DEVELOPING ON IT
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN OF STATE AS
WELL YOU'RE NOT WASTING- YOU
KNOW- SIX YEARS AGO IN YOU KNOW
PLANS. INFORMATION THERE ONLINE
THERE ARE CURRENTLY NO IS NOT
FACTORED A PROBLEM UNIQUE ALL
WEEK THE GOVERNMENT. PLANS IN. I
FROM. SENTENCE OPERATORS. ALL
LOCAL CONTACT. AND OFTENTIMES
MEN TO COUNTIES IN LOCAL SOURCE
THAT YOU CAN EASILY ARE ALWAYS
INVITED. AND I WILL DO. JOB OUR
END TRYING TO BE SURE THAT WE
REACH OUT. YEAH- AND BETTER TO
PULL YOU KNOW OFFICERS. IN
MAINTENANCE FOR CLINTON I AM
LOOKING AT- INCREASING THAT-
POSTURES WILL. AND I KNOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN AT DR
BONHAM ALSO DID WANT TO RESPOND.
TWO QUICK RESPONSES ONE THING WE
DID IN THIS BILL WHICH WAS AN
IMPROVEMENT OVER OUR PRIOR. A
LOT BIGGER STILL IN SANTA
BARBARA WAS WE MUCH MORE QUICKLY.
ROTHROCK COUNTIES OF ORANGE AND
SAN DIEGO AND SHOULD THE COMMAND
POST AND A UNIFIED COMMAND. AND
DEVELOPED A RHYTHM WHERE ALL THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS EVERY OTHER
DAY FOR A PERIOD WERE REPORTING
OUT WHAT THEY WERE STRUGGLING
WITH WHAT THEY WERE SEEING AND
HOW THEY WERE HANDLING. SECOND
WE DID THAT IN PART BECAUSE WE
NEEDED TO COUNTY'S EXPERTISE ON
PUBLIC HEALTH. YOU COUNTIES IN
THIS BILL. IMPLEMENTED WATER AND
SEDIMENT AND AIR SAMPLING SITES
AND ROAMING MONITORING. OVER
FORTY FOR SENTIMENTAL WATER
QUALITY SITES FROM ON SHERMAN
SAN DIEGO OVER EIGHTY- SAMPLE
SITES AND ORANGE COUNTY WE
NEEDED TO COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ALL DIRECTLY A CLOSER TO
AREAS OF IMPROVEMENT AND I TAKE
RELATIVE SUCCESSES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND CHAIR CUTTING BETWEEN
THE HOURS I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THIS WAS BE USEFUL. BUT I ALSO
THINK WE SHOULD CONSIDER WHETHER
ONCE A YEAR OSPREY DOES A
WORKSHOP WITH COASTAL MEMBERS.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
FOR ME AS I WAS CALLING TO
INTRODUCE MYSELF. EMBATTLED AT
THE SAME TIME AND NOW WE'RE ALL
STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING ON AT THE SAME TIME SOME
OF THESE TOPICS ARE HIGHLY
TECHNICAL AND I WONDER WHETHER A
ONCE A YEAR KIND OF INFORMAL
WORKSHOP WITH BOTH CHAMBERS WITH
COASTAL MEMBERS WHICH IS HAVE
OUR CONNECTIVITY A LITTLE BIT
STRONGER YOU ARE FAMILIAR WHERE
HE A LITTLE BIT BETTER PRE
STILL. NOT DURING SCHOOL. THANK
YOU FOR THAT SUGGESTION I THINK
THAT IS AT A- EXCELLENT IDEA AND
TAKE AWAY AS WE- COME OUT OF
THIS CONVERSATION TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M I'M NOT.
SURE OF NOT DONE OKAY. I DIDN'T
HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION I'M AND
THEN VERIFY TO MOVE ONTO THE
NEXT MEMBER IF I'VE GOT A COUPLE
ACTUALLY JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP
WITH. THAT COMMENT- CHERRY BLOOM
IF YOU CAN ALSO WATCH YOU'RE
LOOKING TO THE BUDGET PROCESS.
AS THE ACT DONE TO OFFER
CONSIDERED THE ILLOGICAL AREAS
AS WELL- ALLOWING THEM TO ALSO
HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE OIL SPILL
BECAUSE THIS OIL SPILL IS
DIRECTLY GOING TO. POTENTIALLY
NEGATIVELY IMPACT BOTH THE CHICA
CONSERVANCY- AND I KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF DIFFERENT CONSERVANCY
IN ORANGE COUNTY AS WELL AND I'M
SURE ACROSS THE STATE- BUT I
THINK IF ALLOWING THEM TO BE
INCLUDED. AND MOST OF THEM ARE
NONPROFIT BOTH THE CHEEK OF THE
NONPROFIT. MAY EVEN TO WORK WITH
THE CITY TO HAVE THEIR OWN PLAN
TO COURT WITH THE CITY THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. THANK YOU. AND
THEN- MEL JUST WANT ONE MORE
QUESTION IS AND I'M NOT SURE IF
IT'S EITHER- THE DIRECTOR
ADMINISTRATOR- OR MAYBE LATER
BUT IN REGARDS TO THE CARGO
SHIPS. ARE THEY GIVEN NOTICES
WHERE THESE PIPELINES ARE AS
THEIR APPROACHING OUR SHORELINES
IF SO WHEN AND HOW. BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY OUT THERE. AND
NOW THAT WE KNOW THAT IT IS A
CARGO SHIP. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S IT DOESN'T OCCUR AGAIN
AND SO I'M I'M CURIOUS TO KNOW
OF IF THEY GET NOTICES AND WHERE
THESE PIPELINES ARE AND IF SO
HOW DID THEY GET THOSE NOTICES
AND WHEN DID THEY GET THOSE
NOTICES- BEFORE THEY LEAVE.
WHEREVER THEY ARE OR AFTER
POACHING US HOW DOES THAT WORK.
IT MEANT OR DIRECTOR BONHAM OF
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO ONE. RESPOND AND
I CAN'T TELL WHETHER MISTER
COLLINS ON OUR OFFICE AUDIO BUT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS TO THE
QUESTION I THINK IT'S A QUESTION
PRIMARILY TO UNITED STATES COAST
GUARD RELATIVE TO MARITIME
MANAGEMENT IN FEDERAL WATERS
THIS. LARGE CONTAINERS COME INTO
OUR PORTS. I'D LIKE IT'S A
CHANCE TO. MAKE SURE WE CONNECT-
QUALIFIED EXPERTS WITH YOUR
OFFICE AND GET ANSWERS TO YOUR
QUESTIONS BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S OUR DEPARTMENT OR A
STREET CORNER JURISDICTION.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
WILL TAKE THAT AS A AS A FOLLOW
UP AS WELL ASSEMBLY MEMBER READ
US AND THEN WE WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR SECOND PANEL THANK YOU I
HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR MR BROWN
FROM THE ORANGE COUNTY COAST
KEEPER- DO YOU THINK THAT WE
SHOULD ASSUME THAT OIL AND GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS FORTY
YEARS OLD WILL HAVE PROBLEMS. IS
ARE THE IS THERE OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS OLD ON OUR
COAST. YES YOU ARE. THE OBVIOUS
IS THAT WE HAVE AGING SYSTEMS
OUT THERE IN THE QUESTION IS
THERE THE MONEY BY THE OPERATORS
TO KEEP THEM AT THE STATE THEY
SHOULD BE- JUST. POINT IT IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THERE'S A R. O.
V. DOES A SURVEY OF THE PIPES
BETWEEN L. A. PLATFORM L. A. N.
EUREKA. AND IN THE SURVEY IT
CAME BACK AND SAID THERE'S TWO
FIFTY FOUR TO SPARE ROOMS OF THE
OIL PIPELINE COMING FROM LA.
THAT ARE SUSPENDED THEY'RE NOT
IT'S NOT EVEN ON THE GROUND-
WATER PASSES UNDER IT- I'M NOT
HERE TO SAY THAT'S A GOOD THING
OR BAD THING BUT WHO REVIEWS
THAT AND WHO DETERMINES AND-
WHO. HAS CORRECTIVE ACTION IN MY
FIRST THOUGHT IS A BOY THAT
WOULD BE AN EASY CATCH FOR A
BOAT ANCHOR- IF IT'S NOT EVEN ON
THE GROUND. HIMSELF YOU KNOW YES
IT IS IN AND THAT'S BEEN ONE OF
OUR ISSUES IS. ARE THE OPERATORS
DOING EVERYTHING THEY SHOULD BE
DOING M. YOU KNOW I WOULD HATE
TO THINK THEY'RE JUST WAITING
FOR SOMETHING TO HAPPEN THEN
THEY'LL FIX IT- AND THAT THAT
THAT WE ALL LOSE. IN THAT AND
SO- YES THAT'S WHY THEY NEED TO
START A DIGGY DECOMMISSIONING
PROCESS IN. RIGHT NOW. EVERY
PLATFORM WILL SAY WELL OUR PLAN
IS TO DO COMMISSION BY SUCH AND
SUCH A DATE THAT'S BASED ON WHEN
THEY THINK THEY'RE GOING TO RUN
OUT OF OIL TO PUMP- M. M. A.
IT'S NOT BASED ON THE NEED. TO
DECOMMISSION AND YOU KNOW WE
BROUGH WHEN WE WERE DOING THE
BILL BACK THEN WE SIT DOWN WITH
OIL COMPANIES AND IN THEY WERE
VERY ENCOURAGED TO TRY TO FIND A
WAY. TO EXPEDITE THE
DECOMMISSIONING BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW WHEN OIL WAS IS EIGHTY FIVE
NINETY DOLLARS THEY'RE DOING
WELL IF THESE OIL IS UNDER
SEVENTY DOLLARS A BARREL THEY'RE
LOSING MONEY. AND IT'S CHEAPER
TO RUN THAT WAS AT A LOSS REMIT
IS. TO FACE FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO TAKE HIM OUT. AND SO-
YOU WHAT WE'VE WE'VE DEVELOPED
THIS SYSTEM BUT WE CAN FIX IT.
AND THE OIL COMPANIES WANT TO
FIX IT TOO. SO IT DESERVED AS
THE CHORE SAYING IT IT. YOU KNOW.
OUR DON'T THINK NEED LARGE. TO
BAN ANYTHING WHICH BASIS GOING
TO REACH IN LAWSUITS AND M.
ALLOWED BATTLE. I THINK WE
SHOULD TRY COLLABORATION FIRST
AND I'VE I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE
NEEDED TO DO AND DO IT SURE.
BALK AT THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
ARE. MISTER BROWN AND THAT TO
OUR OTHER PANELISTS FOR JOINING
US TODAY THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
BEING PATIENT WITH OUR TECHNICAL
HURDLES AND DIET CERTAINLY-
FEELS LIKE A CONVERSATION WE
WILL VERY MUCH CONTINUE IN THE
WEEKS AND MONTHS AHEAD. WITH
THAT WE WILL TAKE A LIKE A TWO
MINUTE BREAK WHILE WE GET OUR
SECOND PANELIST AT READY TO GO
AND JAM. I THANK YOU AGAIN SO
MUCH APPRECIATE YOU AND THAT AND
ALL YOU TO FORGE COUNTY. THANK
YOU DIRECTOR. THANK YOU.
CORRECT
WE ARE BACK FIVE I WOULD LIKE TO
NOW INTRODUCE OUR NEXT PANEL AT
THE CENTER TO THE NEXT COLLEGE
PIPELINE REGULATION AND SAFETY
WE ARE BEING JOINED REMOTELY BY
A COUPLE OF A PANELIST JENNIFER
WE K<c.cyan> THE CASEY FROM THE</c>
CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION. MIKE RICH WINE FROM
THE OFFICE OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE FIRE MARSHAL. CHIEF JIM
HAUSSLER FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FIRE MARSHAL.
AND BILL KAREN WHO IS HERE WITH
US IT NOT IN THREE DIMENSIONS
FROM THE PIPELINE SAFETY TRUST
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US I
BELIEVE OUR OTHER PANELISTS ARE.
ON THE PHONE I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
OF MR CARRIM AND- AND TO BEGIN
WITH YOU THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
YOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MY NAME IS
BILL. THANK GOD FOR BOEING IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE HI MY
FAILURE. WE'RE NOT LINE RUPTURED
IT'S BUILT A QUARTER MILLION
GALLONS OF GASOLINE INTO A CREEK
AND HEAVILY USED CITY PARK THE
ENTIRELY PREVENTABLE FAILURE AND
THE SUBSEQUENT EXPLOSION AND
FIRE STOLE THE LIVES OF THREE
BOYS DAMAGE THE CITY'S WATER
TREATMENT FACILITY AND BURNED
ALMOST TWO MILES OF A SALMON
STREAM THAT RUNS THROUGH THE
CENTER OF TOWN. THE FAMILIES OF
THE BOYS WHO DIED IN THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE SUCCESSFULLY
PUSHED FOR THE FUNDING OF THE
TRUST. AS PART OF A CRIMINAL
PENALTIES PAID BY THE OPERATOR
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FAILURE.
CREATING A PUBLIC INTEREST
WATCHDOG TO IMPROVE PIPELINE
SAFETY. THE PIPELINE SAFETY
TRUST IS THE ONLY NATIONAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
FOCUSES ON PIPELINE SAFETY. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY AS YOU WORK
TO EXTRACT LESSONS FROM THE
OCTOBER FAILURE OF THE AMPLIFY
ENERGY PIPELINE AND DETERMINE
WHAT ACTIONS MIGHT BE AVAILABLE
TO THE ASSEMBLY TO PREVENT
ADDITIONAL SPILLS AND TO IMPROVE
THE RESPONSE TO THOSE BILLS THAT
TO HAPPEN. I WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS
MY TESTIMONY ON TOOLS THE
ASSEMBLY HAS TO REQUIRE MORE
FROM PIPELINE OPERATORS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ANY REGULATORY
GAPS TO ADDRESS TO HELP PREVENT
FUTURE SPILLS AND IMPROVE
RESPONSE TO SUCH BILLS. I WOULD
LIKE TO IDENTIFY FOR THE
COMMITTEE A POTENTIALLY POWERFUL
TOOL TO ADOPT STRICTER
REGULATIONS FOR FEDERALLY
REGULATED INTERSTATE PIPELINES
OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA. THE
FEDERAL OIL POLLUTION ACT
ENACTED IN RESPONSE TO THE EXXON
VALDEZ SPILL ALLOW STATES TO
REQUIRE STRONGER PLANS THAN THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS UNDER OIL
SPILL PREVENTION LOS. AS I
OUTLINED VARIOUS REGULATORY GAPS
I WILL IDENTIFY THOSE AREAS
WHICH THE ASSEMBLY COULD
POSSIBLY ADDRESS WITH THIS
AUTHORITY. I WILL BRIEFLY
DISCUSS PIPELINE SAFETY
REGULATORY GAPS IN FOUR MAIN
AREAS CONSTRUCTION SPILL PLANS
INSPECTIONS AND WE DETECTION.
THEN THE REGULATIONS STATE THAT
ALL OFFSHORE PIPE IN WATER
BETWEEN TWELVE AND TWO HUNDRED
FEET IN DEPTH MUST BE BELOW THE
UNDERWATER NATURAL BOTTOM UNLESS
THE PAPER SUPPORTED BY
STANCHIONS HELD IN PLACE BY
ANCHORS OR HEAVY CONCRETE
COATING. THIS FAILURE SITE WAS
LOCATED AT NINETY EIGHT FEET IN
DEPTH WHICH IS WITHIN THIS RANGE
AND WAS AT ONE POINT COVERED IN
CONCRETE. WE HOPE THE
INVESTIGATION TELLS US WHEN THE
CONCRETE COVER WAS DISTURBED AND
BROKEN. AND WHETHER THAT WAS
RELATED TO THE PIPES FAILURE.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS FILM THE
REGULATION ONLY APPLIES AT THE
TIME OF CONSTRUCTION AND
INSTALLATION THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT THAT ANY PARTICULAR
DEPTH OR CONCRETE PROTECTION BE
MAINTAINED OVER THE LIFE OF THE
PIPELINE. WE HOPE TO SEE
REGULATIONS UPDATED TO REQUIRE
ONGOING MAINTENANCE OF DEPTH OR
PROTECTION. IMPROVEMENTS TO
SPILL RESPONSE PLAN REQUIREMENTS
HAVE BEEN A PRIORITY THE
PIPELINE SAFETY TRUST FOR YEARS.
THESE PLANS ARE KEPT MOSTLY
HIDDEN FROM OUTSIDE INPUT AND
SCRUTINY. AMPLIFY HAD A SPILL
RESPONSE PLAN IN PLACE THAT HAD
BEEN APPROVED BY FEMSA. WE DON'T
YET HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION TO
KNOW HOW CLOSELY THEY FOLLOWED
THAT PLAN. HOWEVER THERE ARE
SOME IMPROVEMENTS TO STATE LAWS
TO BE MADE HERE. THIS IS AN AREA
I BELIEVE CALIFORNIA COULD USE
ITS FEDERAL OIL POLLUTION ACT
AUTHORITY. FOR EXAMPLE
CALIFORNIA COULD REQUIRE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD ON THIS
BILL PLANS WASHINGTON STATE
WHO'S DONE THIS. THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE PUBLIC LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER AGENCIES
TO KNOW IF AN OPERATOR HAS
PROPERLY IDENTIFIED SENSITIVE
AREAS AND IS ADEQUATELY PREPARED
TO PROTECT THEM AND WHETHER THE
RESPONSE RESOURCES ARE ADEQUATE
AND AVAILABLE IN A TIMELY MANNER.
FEDERAL REGULATORS REVIEWING
SPILL PLANS DO NOT HAVE THE KIND
OF LOCAL KNOWLEDGE THAT IS
IMPERATIVE IN DETERMINING THE
ADEQUACY OF A SPILL RESPONSE
PLAN. AS FAR AS INSPECTIONS
ACCORDING TO MEDIA REPORTS
AMPLIFI CONDUCTED AN IN LINE
INSPECTION IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
AND TWO OF THE IDENTIFIED EIGHT
ANOMALIES HAD BEEN REPAIRED
BEFORE THE OCTOBER FAILURE. WE
DO NOT YET HAVE INFORMATION AS
TO WHETHER THE FAILURE SITE
CORRESPONDS TO ONE OF THE
IDENTIFIED ANOMALIES. THE FILM
THE INTEGRITY MANAGEMENT RULES
THAT APPLY TO THIS LINE WOULD
REQUIRE AN ASSESSMENT ONCE EVERY
FIVE YEARS. WE BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA COULD AS PART OF ITS
OIL SPILL PREVENTION LAWS
REQUIRE MORE FREQUENT
ASSESSMENTS OF WHETHER THE
PIPELINE HAS MOVED ON THE BOTTOM
OF THE OCEAN FLOOR. U. S.
CONGRESS AMENDED THE PIPELINE
SAFETY STATUTES IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. TO REQUIRE ANNUAL
INTERNAL INSPECTIONS BECAUSE
PIPELINE ROUTE SURVEYS AND OTHER
ASSESSMENTS ON A RISK ADJUSTED
SCHEDULE ON CERTAIN UNDERWATER
PIPELINES. HOWEVER IT DOES NOT
APPLY TO OFFSHORE PIPE. THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE COULD
ADOPT NEW LEGISLATION EXTENDING
THESE REQUIREMENTS TO INTEREST
STATE OFFSHORE LINES UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE OFFICE THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL AND WORK WITH
YOUR CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION TO
EXTEND THEM TO ALL UNDERWATER
PIPELINES. IN THIS CORRECT
CORRECTIVE ACTION ORDER STATED
THAT AMPLIFY OBSERVED A LOW
PRESSURE ALARM ON IT SKATE A
SYSTEM SEVERAL HOURS BEFORE THEY
NOTIFY THE NATIONAL RESPONSE
CENTER OF THIS BILL. LIKE MANY
OPERATORS THE ONLY LEAK
DETECTION SYSTEM THAT APPLE PIE
HAS THIS PRESSURE SENSORS AS
PART OF ITS SKATE A SYSTEM. ALL
THE IN THE REGULATIONS REQUIRE
IS THAT AN OPERATOR HAVE SOME
SORT OF LEAK DETECTION SYSTEM.
THERE ARE NO PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS AS TO HOW SENSITIVE
ACCURATE RELIABLE OR ROBUST THAT
SYSTEM SHOULD BE. ALASKA HAS
UNDER ITS OIL SPILL PREVENTION
LAWS ADOPTED PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS FOR ITS PIPELINES IN
CALIFORNIA COULD WORK WITH
ALASKA AS PART OF THE PACIFIC
STATES BRITISH COLUMBIA OIL
SPILL TASK FORCE TO CRAFT NEW
PROTECTIVE LANGUAGE BASED ON HOW
ALASKA HAS ACCOMPLISHED THIS. I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THIS TESTIMONY TODAY I'M
ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AND TO WORK WITH YOU
FURTHER AS YOU FIND WAYS TO KEEP
YOUR BEAUTIFUL STATE. INCLUDING
A TREASURE COAST LINE SAPER FROM
PIPELINE FAILURES. AND HANK YOU
MISTER PATTON. AT LET'S NOT GO
TO AT JENNIFER LEE CASEY WHO'S
JOINING US FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN. FINE MORNING CARE
HEATING ARE INTERMITTENTLY
NUMBERS MAIN AGENDA REALLY HEAVY
AND THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE DISCUSSIONS
TODAY THE STATE AUTHORITY
ATHLETE IN HISTORY OF COMPLEX
AND NUANCED AND IF EIGHTY
OBVIOUSLY ENERGY POLICY FROM THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES AND SIXTIES ARE
VERY DIFFERENT FROM CALIFORNIA
AND VALUES AND IMPLEMENTABLE AND
OUR POLICY PRIORITY THAT TODAY.
ALREADY LEGACY DECADES OLD AND
ENERGY POLICIES AREWHAT CREATED
A LEGAL CONSTITUTIONAL
CONTRACTUAL FRAMEWORK THAT
DICTATE THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
OIL AND GAS LEASE MANAGEMENT
BRING KRAMER TO THIS DAY AND
WILL NECESSARILY INFORM YOUR
DISCUSSION AND DELIBERATION I
HAVE WOULD BE AND ARE SHARED
CLEAN ENERGY AND JUST HANDED IN
A JACKET. IT IS COMPLEX BUT. NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO ADDRESS- DID BACK
SIGNATURE. THE STATE FOLLOWING
TRY. BUT INCLUDE A POCKET AND
TWENTY. SLATED FOR LATE AND LYFT
ALONG OVERLY HUNDRED MILES OF
THE COAST BY. AND UNDERLYING THE
THAT- OCEAN AND HOW THREE MILES
THE STATE THAT ALL DOWN THREE.
IT MIGHT CAN ALSO AFTER OVERHEAD
ALREADY OVER THE STATE PUBLICLY
BRING IN BY. ACROSS EIGHTY LOW-
THE OFFSHORE LONG BEACH A LOT.
MANAGER THE CITY LONG- COMMITTEE
ON REGULARLY FONG FUNCTION IT IS
QUITE A IN IN REGARDS AGENCY NOT.
AGENT IN ORDER TO FEDERAL BUREAU
OCEAN MANAGEMENT AND OF AND I.
ENFORCEMENT AND THE BUREAU OF
LAND MANAGEMENT ON YOUR- OIL AND
GAS AUTHORED ABILITY THEN HIGH
FLYING LOCATED EXCLUSIVELY IN
STATE WATER. INFRASTRUCTURE TO
MANAGE GROWTH INITIALLY FROM THE
COMMISSION OR IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT GRANTS SHE- REALLY
HIGH WIND THAT ARE LOCATED ONLY
WITHIN CITY BOUNDARIES INCLUDING
STATE WATER AT ALL INTRASTATE.
AND ANY OTHER REGULATED. BY THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL. WHERE DOES
ACROSS THE WATER CONNECT BACK
OFFICE FIVE BUT ON SORT OF THE-
BEAST WIDE OPEN. A INTERSTATE
PIPELINE AND THAT'LL GO THROUGH
THE HIGH FLYING HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS IT. KIND OF PRIMARY.
AUTHORITY THE COMMISSION EIGHT
FIVE MARSHAL CAL. AND THAT ALL
GLASS TO GET. HE EARNED IN A AND
COMPLIANCE. TO ANALEIGH. DIDN'T
A SHORT A COORDINATED ANALYTICAL
FRAMEWORK FOR REGULATION. AND
IMPLEMENTATION AND COMPLIANCE.
CERTAINLY IN REGULATING ANY ANY
AND PIPELINE THAT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS PRIMARY SERVICED
A AND AUTHORITY. TAKING A STEP
BACK IN NINETEEN ONE THE LATEST
TO CREATE A FOR PILOT OILY GAS
LEADING. THE ABILITY NOT SURELY
THE COMMISSION RESPONSIBLE FOR
MANAGING WERE ISSUED OVER A
THIRTY YEAR PERIOD BETWEEN.
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT AND
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. IN
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE LEGISLATURE
HAPPENED CUNNINGHAM SHALL ACT
WITH WHICH THIRD OF THE
FOUNDATIONAL LAW PRETTY GOOD IS
BEING WILING ATHLETE THE CURRENT
COMMISSION CURRENTLY MANAGES.
AND THE EXACTLY. THE COMMISSION
SO ISSUE EXACTLY OR TERM NOT
BASED ON HERE FOR SO LONG AND
OIL AND GAS AND PRODUCE AND HANG
QUANTITIES. ASSEMBLY IT MEANS
THAT LACK THE HAVE REDUCE THE
OIL AND GAS- STEVEN WITHIN THEIR
STATELY INDEFINITELY AS LONG AS
IT IS ECONOMIC FOR THEM TO DO
SO. THE DEFINITIVE TURNITIN
INCLUDED IN ALL REMAIN A LACK
ELEVEN ACCURATELY FOR USING OFF
EARLY TO THE COMMISSION MANAGES.
THE LEADERS WERE ENTERED INTO
OVER FIFTY YEARS AGO AND PRIOR
TO THE. NINETEEN NINETY OR
HOPEFUL THINGS WERE AT. BRUTAL
OR ACKNOWLEDGE PLACE BEING OF
CALIFORNIA CO OFTEN IT IN NEW
EXACTLY THE. IF YOU CLEARLY
HEARD NUMBER TEACHER WELL
INTERVENTION AND BACK TO THE
PATH NINETY NINETY ONE. BAKKAVOR
THE COMMISSION OF WERE NOT WELL
BUILDER THE STATE OFFER PLATFORM
IN IRELAND THROUGH MONTH AND
BACK. IN COMPREHEND AT THE
EIGHTY ODD CONDUCTED A ALL BY IN
IRELAND. YEAR THE COMMISSION ALL
I'M GONNA GROW BY PIPELINE
SAFETY PROGRAM INCOME LADDER
WITH FIREARM AND THE THAT. MARI
THEY'RE GONNA OF LOT PASS IT
WILL AT IT IF YOU FOR
OCCASIONALLY FOR NEW AND
EMERGING LIKE PIPELINES. THAT
WOULD ONLY HATE NEW ONLY AFTER
ALONE IN BATTLE ARE AND REALLY
PROTECTED LANDING CALIFORNIA.
IMPORTANTLY ARE ALSO IN A NUMBER
OF A LOT OF IT HAD ADDED TOOLS
OF THE COMMISSION TO LOCK BETTER
MANAGE AND REGULATE EXISTING
DATA ONTAP OPERATION IN THE
NUMBER THE FASTER. AND PER
CAPITA DATE RYAN EARLY.
EVERYBODY THERE. ARE A LOT OF
THE WAR I WOULD BEING TO SHARE
THAT AMOUNT. AND HOPEFULLY THOSE
MAPS AND WILL BE PROVIDED TO YOU
THROUGH THE SHARE- AT YOUR AT
THE EARLIEST CONVENIENCE
POSSIBLE BUT I WANTED TO SHARE
GET. AT A STATE OF PLAY IN TERMS
OF THE EXISTING ALSO RUNNING
ATHLETE IS. AND HIGHLIGHTING THE
SAYS THAT THE COMMISSION
MANAGES. AND IN ORDER SHALL WE
HAVE ACTED ILLEGALLY USING
LEASES. REVERTED TO THE LAST
MONTH HALL OPERATION THESE AYE
WELL. FROM ON SHORE
DIRECTIONALLY OFFSHORE. WE ALSO
HAVE EIGHT ACTIVE PIPELINE
NEEDED CONNECTING BARREL
PLATFORM DONS ARE PROFITING
DELETE. IN ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE
ONE RELEASE THAT- OIL AND GAS.
PRODUCING. LEGAL I NG. WE HAVE
ONE WE OF THE WITH. AFTER WE
HAVE FINALLY AT THE WITH ANY. I
MEAN IT'S REALLY TO THE REST OF
THE IN A CLASS AT A- WE HAVE
APPETITE LANGLEY CONNECT. THAT
CLASS ON YOUR **** TO THE- TO
YOU A PLATFORM- ALLEY HAD A SURE
HIKE LANGLEY. WELL HAVE THREE
ACTIVE PIPELINE LEADERS. CLUB
AFTER ATTA ANY ON OR ABOUT THE
FACILITY. THE ONLY BE ALLOWED
LONG BEACH IS THE FOUR LETTER
OIL ON AMERICA INTERESSIEREN
APACHE GREENAN. THE CITY LONG
EVEN CONSIDER OFFER AND- TELL ME
TO THE CORE IN THE CITY CONTRA.
DIDN'T INCLUDE THAT OR I.
OFFSHORE LONG BEACH AND
ELECTRONIC IN OPERATION AND WE
ARE PRIMARILY LOCATED UNDER THE
PORT OF LONG BEACH. THAT IS A
REPEAT OF THE MINISTER OF THE
NECROPOLIS THAT THEY WOULD BE
OPERATION BUT IT OPERATION ARE
NOT MANAGER TYPICAL LEFT OR LEFT
THE RELATIONSHIP AND THEREFORE
THE COMMISSION IS VERY LIMITED
AUTHORITY OVER. THE MANAGEMENT
OF THE OPERATION. AT A PARTY
ONLY A IS AN IMPACT MONEY TO THE
COMMUNITY REQUIRED OPERATE TO
PAY- MARK RAN. MAINTAINED BY
INSURANCE THAT RELY. PROTECTION
PROTECT THE STATE. AND THAT
EARLY THE WHOLE YOUR- COMMISSION
FROM NEW OIL GAS PRODUCTION IN
THE THAT. THAT POLICY HAS AMOUNT
AND WHERE THEY CAN BY TO TELL.
PRIORITIZING LEADING THE STATE
EVEN. DAY MANY OF THE I TO THE.
AND I LEAD ME TO THE FINAL
MICHAEL. I RECOGNIZE THAT YOU
HIGHLANDER THAT BIT OF THE TO
FIND CRIED THAT REQUIRED THE
STATE TO RADICALLY HANG THE WAY
COULD YOU DIDN'T CAME BACK. AND
AT THERE THE BRIDGE TO THE. YEAH
COMMITTEE IT PART BUILDING RIGHT.
AND A LANDOWNING TO BE REPEAT
THE MANAGE OF FORM EIGHT OF THE
PUBLIC LAND. WE ARE WORKING TO-
OUR LEADING AND RUNNING. FOR ON
A- AND IT IS IN OUR TO BE
PARTNERED AND AS- MARKETING
ENERGY. DIDN'T INCLUDE PERSONAL
HARLEM TRACK THAT. G. R. SOLAR
AND WIND ALAMAT. ACCURATELY
WORKING ON FEET AND PARTNERS OUR
LACK. SHOULD IDOLS AT OF THEIR-
REQUIREMENTS. TO ENSURE THE
STATE AT LEGAL THROUGH BOND
THINKING BOND PROPERTY LEAN IRAQ.
DECOMMISSIONING ALSO ABILITY
LIKE MORE MOLLY IN REALLY HIGH.
REMAIN OFF ORDER. WELL AND
IMPLEMENTING ROBUST IN AND BILL
PREVENTS AND PASSION AND- IN
BACK ON LAST. YEARS THAT HAD
THAT ABILITY A TURNING. HAD ALSO
OILING LEASES REGARDING- OVER
TWENTY EIGHT AND A LITTLE BANKS
WORRY. ANY CONCLUSION THE
COMMISSION UNDERSTAND EVEN
THOUGH CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY AND
ITS FUTURE A BOTTLE OF YOUR
COMPLIANCE DEPENDENCY. COMMITTED
TO ADAPT RENDITION OF ALL
RESPONSIBILITY MANAGING THE
STATE EXISTING MINING OPERATION
CONSISTENT WITH A LOT ENSURING
THAT THE STATE IS PROTECTED FROM
LIABILITY ASSOCIATED WITH A
DECLINE IN THE OFFSHORE
OPERATIONS. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU SHARE AND YOUR
COLLEAGUE. ANNE OF FAMILY AND
THE SENATE ON- IDENTIFYING DATA
MACINNES THEM TO ACHIEVING. OUR
SHARED GOAL THANK YOU. FOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH I NOW WE'RE TO HEAR
FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FIVE MARSHAL
LEAVE CAUGHT CHIEF MY RICH WINE
AND SHE JIM JOINING US. HERE
PETER MORRIS CAN YOU HEAR ME OK.
YEAH YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT SOFT SO
PERHAPS SAID. GET CLOSER TO THE
MICROPHONE OUR PROJECT. THANK
YOU- THANK YOU SHARE AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY MY NAME IS MIKE
RESTORING AND I'M IN THE
CALIFORNIA CITY FIRE MARSHAL
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY WHEN THEY WERE SHARING
WILL STILL. IN THE ROLE OF THE
OPPOSITE STATE FIRE MARSHAL IN
PIPELINE SAFETY- MY TESTIMONY
WITH THE DIFFERENT OF HOW WE
REGULARLY WILL. BUT I'M GOING TO
CALIFORNIA WHAT WE DID IN THIS
PARTICULAR INCIDENT AND I'LL BE
FOLLOWING BUT I KEEP GETTING
AUTHOR WHO OVERSEES ARE WHEN
DEFEATED. THE MORE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DIVISION
THERE ARE CURRENT LAWS AND
REGULATIONS GOVERNING. PIPELINE
SAFETY. THE OTHER DAY FOR
ARTICLE. SEASON DEBUT IN FOR A
STATE HAS LIQUID PIPE AND- STAFF
INSPECT OPERATOR JEWISH
COMPLIANCE WITH AND STATE PARK
GOING TO LAW ERIC. IN YOUR
MANAGEMENT EXCLUSIVE SAFETY
REGULATORY AND ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY OVER INTERSTATE
HAZARDOUS LIQUID PIPELINES IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH CERTIFICATION
FIVE HUNDRED ONE HUNDRED IS
MATERIAL SAFETY ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT OFFENDS- WE WOULD ONE
CARRYING TO JUST GOOGLE YEAH JET
FUEL HELLO LIQUID AND OTHER
HYDROCARBONS. IN INTERSTATE
HUNDRED LIQUID PIPELINE IT IF
I'M GOING THAT IS LOCATED
ENTIRELY WITHIN THE BORDERS OF
THE CITY CALIFORNIA INCLUDING.
OFFSHORE STATE WATERS. MAINTAIN
EXCLUDE FOR AUTHORITY OVER IN
FIVE OR- WITH ARE PROBABLY LINES
THAT CROSS THE BORDERS OR THE
GAME IN FEDERAL WATERS. I'M SAID
ON FRIDAY OCTOBER FIRST THE
OPPOSITE OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL FIVE POINT EIGHTY
THERE'S AN WITH NOTIFIED THAT IT
OWNED I DON'T KNOW JEAN. IN
WATERS OFF OF. THESE. AT
EIGHTEEN THIRTY HOURS. DURING
THE OF THE NEEDS VERIFY HIM FOR.
AND CONTACT OPERATORS OR OVER
TO. THE OPERATORS REPORTED A
LOSS OF PRESSURE IN THE MOVIE
THAT ITALY. ONE HE UP SAID WE NO
FROM THE NASA RESPONSE THERE A
LITTLE LEAGUE WE CONTINUE TO
REACH OUT TO THE BY OPERATORS
FOR OWNERSHIP AND VERIFICATION.
ONE OCTOBER THIRD SENDING
MORNING I SHOULD SAY ON OCTOBER
THIRD AFTER MAYBE ALL THAT THEN
REGULATED BY GOING TO THE
POSSIBLE STORES WE CONTACTED
THEM BUT IF I DO HAVE THE
POSSIBILITY. OF GOING UNDER
THEIR JURISDICTION THEY WERE
WEARING FROM THE NATIONAL
RESPONSE CENTER. AND WE'RE
MOBILIZING. WE MET WE MET WITH
THE RECORD THAT MORE AND HE
INCIDENT POST. THAT DALLAS THE
US COAST GUARD. IN ORDER TO BE
IN MY LIFE ALL OKAY. ON ALL THE
YEAH HE P. OR A APPLE PIE DATA
OFFSHORING YEAH OF THE
COMMISSION SENATE OFFICE
AMERICAN SERVICES IN GENERAL
MOTORS NATIONAL FIRE A. IT IS AN
HONOR TO TECHNICAL TO THE BEN
THE AND OTHER ASIAN THAT. IN A
PREVIOUS MENTIONED ONE OF THE
ELDERS CALIFORNIA NINE POINT
EIGHTY NOW EIGHTY ONE THE BILL
FARMER OKAY AFTER THAT I DIDN'T.
AB REGULATORY. OVER PERTH FIVE
ONE. FIVE NINE. ABOUT A LONG AND
THEREFORE THE NOT FALL UNDER THE
JURORS OF THE THAT THE FINAL.
THANK YOU FOR TODAY OF OUR IN
THE IMPORTANT HERE. IN OUR NINE
INTERVIEWS YOU GET ALONG WORK
WILL PROVIDE MORE DETAIL ABOUT
THE MARKET ROLE IN BY WEDNESDAY
DE. PODER YOUR THE FLOOR. THANK
GOOD MORNING TO MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JIM ALL. AND I THIS IS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CHIEF OF THE PIPE STATE
DIVISION. THANK YOU FOR
MEDITATION TODAY AND NOT PURSUE.
THIS WITH YOU. THE THIS. IS THE
PRIMARY ROLE IN RESPONSE. THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO WITH. THE OLDER
IDEA OF. NUMBER FOR THE PIPE
STATE OF IT. HER ROLE IN THE
RESPONSE. MONITOR TRANSFER
PIPELINE. TO ENSURE COMPLY WITH.
PERFORM FIELD INSPECTIONS OF
OPERATORS ACCESS. MONITORED
REVIEW BODY PROTECTION PRACTICES
PROCEDURES AND POLICIES.
INVESTIGATE EVERY RUSHER
EXPLOSION TRAIN AROUND THAT WERE
FIRED FOLLOWING A PIPELINE UNDER
THE PIPELINE SAFETY DIVISIONS
ACCORDING. IT IS MANDATED TO
PERFORM INSPECTIONS BASED ON THE
FEDERAL CODE AND THE STATE OF.
THE TIME FRAMES FOR INSPECTIONS
CAN VERY BASED ON INSPECTION
HIGH. AND INSPECT OPERATORS MORE
FREQUENTLY IF NECESSARY TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE. NOW HOW OFTEN
ARE THE INSPECTIONS DONE AND
WHAT PROTECTIONS ARE IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THE SILENCERS SAY.
INSPECTIONS ARE CONDUCTED
ANNUALLY UNDER STATE
REQUIREMENTS THE FEDERAL
INSPECTIONS ARE PERFORMED EVERY
FIVE YEARS DEPENDING ON A
PIPELINE FACILITY HIRING WORKERS
REALLY ARE ALL. IRISES LEADING
MAINTENANCE ACTED MORE
FREQUENTLY BUT IT IS NOT
REQUIRED ON THE FEDERAL MANDATE.
REFUGIO AND HOW HOW IT IMPROVED
ARE PIPELINE SAFETY PROGRAM. ID
TWENTY FIFTEEN THERE WAS A
SIZEABLE STILL ON LAND IT FLOWED
INTO THE OCEAN IN SANTA BARBARA
NEAR REFUGIO STATE BEACH.
FOLLOWING THE SALE SEVERAL
LONGER PASSAGE EIGHT EIGHT IS
STRICTLY. STATE PIPELINE SAFETY
LAW. EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY FOUR
TWENTY SIXTEEN DAS WILLIAMS. RT
IS THE BEST AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY
ON FIVE LINES THAT COULD IMPACT
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE AREAS
OF THE COASTAL. SOME OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES REMOTE- INCLUDE
REMOTE CONTROL VALVES. THE R. P.
F. PARTY'S WILSHIRE- AND
EMERGENCY FLOW RESTRICTING
DEVICES. LEAK DETECTION SYSTEMS
AUTOMATIC SHUTDOWN SYSTEM THERE
ARE OTHER TECHNOLOGIES BUT THESE
ARE SOME OF THE TOP LEVEL- ITEMS
THAT WE HAD A PROGRAM TRIES TO
ADDRESS. SB FIVE TWENTY SIXTEEN
JACKSON REQUIRED THE ANNUAL
INSPECTION OF PIPELINES UNDER
OUR JURISDICTION. THE PASSAGE OF
THE STATUTE A LOT OF THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL TO HIRE ADDITIONAL
STAFF. AND DEVELOPING THE
RESOURCES TO BETTER EXECUTE THIS
MAN IT IS MANDATED TO THE DUTIES
AND GROW TO FILL NEW STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. STATE LAW
CURRENTLY REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
SAFETY TECHNOLOGY APART MINDS
AND MORE FREQUENT INSPECTIONS
THAT REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW AND
REGULATIONS. THE FEDERAL
PIPELINE SAFETY LAW SAID THE
MINIMUM SAFETY STANDARDS THE
PIPELINE OPERATORS MUST COMPLY
WITH. CALIFORNIA EXCEEDS THE
STANDARD MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS IN
SOME AREAS OF OUR STATE LOBBYING
CLOONEY. EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
SB TWO NINETY FIVE. SO CONTACT
ON HER CELL. THE PIPELINE ISSUES
NOT UNDER OUR JURISDICTION
BECAUSE IT IS AN INTERSTATE
PIPELINE. OUR OFFICE ONLY
REGULATE INTERSTATE PIPELINE. IN
GENERAL TERMS OUR OFFICE ONLY
REGULATE PIPELINES ARE LOCATED
WHOLLY ON STATE LAND OR ITS
STATE WATERS BARRING A FEW
EXCEPTIONS. HOWEVER EVEN IF
LOWER BY MINE LOCATED IN STATE
WATERS OR EVEN ON STATE LAND OUR
OFFICE WOULD STILL NOT REGULATE
IT AND IT WOULD NOT BE SUBJECT
TO THE STATE INCREASE INSPECTION
SCHEDULE AND TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGICAL REQUIREMENTS FOUND
IN. EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY FOUR AND
SB THREE NINE FIVE. THE PIPELINE
WOULD NOT BE SUBJECT TO THE
STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE
IT OPERATED A LOW PRESSURE BELOW
THE STATE JURISDICTIONAL
REQUIREMENTS. A LOW PRESSURE
PIPELINE OPERATED A PRESSURE OF
A LOW LEVEL IT IS NOT BECAUSE
MENTAL STRESS BELOW A CERTAIN
PRESSURE BATTERY. THE PIPELINE
FROM LA OR WORRY HERE'S A DAY IN
A LOW PRESSURE FIVE ONE. THE
LEGISLATURE CONTEMPLATED PLATING
LOW PRESSURE TRANSPORTATION
PIPELINES I DON'T REALLY. HAVE
JURISDICTION WITH SB. ONE SIXTY
NINE TWENTY NINETEEN JACKSON.
HOWEVER THAT WILL NOT MAKE IT
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
UNDER EXISTING LAW WE DO NOT
REGULATE LOW PRESSURE PIPELINE
STATE WATER OR ON LAND UNDER THE
MORE STRINGENT CALIFORNIA COAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFYING TODAY HE
RESIGNED AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
YOU OUT WITH THAT ARE WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AS A REMINDER WILL JUST EAT FREE
IN INTEREST. DO YOU WANT
QUESTIONS OF A MORE MINDFUL OF
TIME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RITA.
THANK YOU I'M FIVE ONE QUESTION
FOR THE PIPELINE SAFETY TRUST.
WHAT ARE THE CAPABILITIES OF THE
PAST WEEK DETECTION SYSTEMS AND
HOW QUICKLY WOULD AN OPERATOR
KNOW THAT THEIR SYSTEM COULD BE
LEAKING. IT'S A IT'S A
COMPLICATED QUESTION. THERE'S A
COUPLE COMPONENTS THAT GO INTO A
LEAK DETECTION SYSTEM. YOU KNOW
ONE IS THE VOLUME OF PRODUCT
THAT'S LEAKING VERSES- THE TIME
PERIOD YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT- SO
ANYTIME THERE HAVE BEEN
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS OR MORE
STRICT STANDARDS PUT ONLY
DETECTION SYSTEMS THEY'VE
INVOLVED- RATHER THAN
PRESCRIPTION AS TO WHAT KIND OF
LEAK DETECTION SYSTEM THEY HAVE
TO HAVE THEY'VE BEEN PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS. SO ALASKA'S EXAMPLE
IS- OPERATORS NEED TO HAVE A
LEAK DETECTION SYSTEM CAPABLE OF
PROMPTLY DETECTING A LEAK OF AT
LEAST 1% OF DAILY THROUGHPUT.
WASHINGTON STATE OF WASHINGTON
HAS- ASKED THAT ALL LEAK
DETECTION SYSTEMS MUST BE
CAPABLE OF DETECTING 8% OF
MAXIMUM FLOW RATE WITHIN FIFTEEN
MINUTES. SO THOSE BOTH SEEM TO
BE KIND OF REASONABLE- OPERATORS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO REASONABLY
MEET THOSE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- IF I UNDERSTAND IT
CORRECTLY I THINK THIS QUESTION
WOULD BE FOR- EITHER OF THE-
STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S- THERE'S
ABOUT. FIFTY SIX HUNDRED MILES
OF INTERSTATE PIPELINE AND- AND-
I'M TOLD- AND IF THAT PIPELINE
IS OPERATED AT LOW PRESSURE THEN
THEY'RE SUBJECT TO A FIVE YEAR
INSPECTION REGIMEN AS OPPOSED
TO- ONE TWO YEARS THE STATE
REQUIRES FOR. APPLIES THAT ARE
OPERATED AT HIGHER PRESSURE THAT
ESSENTIALLY CORRECT. EIGHT EIGHT
YES SIR- ESSENTIALLY IT WAS
UNDER STATE- REGULATIONS WHICH
IS FINE LINE IS NOT. IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO BE
INSPECTED ANNUALLY BUT ONCE
AGAIN- DUE TO SB ONE SIXTY NINE
AND A CURRENT REGULATIONS WE
WOULD NOT PAY EVEN OUR PROGRAM
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO.
FORMAT INSPECTION BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T FOLLOW THE CALIFORNIA
CODE BUT IT FALLS UNDER THE
FEDERAL CODE SO WE WOULD HAVE
INSPECTED IT AT THAT- FIVE YEAR
INTERVAL AS WELL. OF FOLLOWING
UP ON THAT WITH THE TWO OF THE-
PIPELINE SAFETY TRUST. ARE WE
ARE THE REASONS A PIPELINE
OPERATOR WHICH USED TO OPERATE
THE PIPELINE AT A LOWER CAPACITY
OR PRESSURE WHAT WITH THOSE
RACES BE- YES THERE ARE REASONS-
IT COULD BE. THAT IS AN AGING
PIPELINE AND THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE SOME WEAKNESSES
AND THAT IT CAN OPERATE MAYBE A
LITTLE SAFER AT ALL AT LOWER
PRESSURE AND- THEY AND NOT TO
PUSH THE ENVELOPE THERE'S ALSO
DEMAND REASONS OF WHY THEY
WOULDN'T WANT TO PUT TOO MUCH
PRODUCT THROUGH IT AT ONE TIME-
STORAGE ISSUES THINGS LIKE THAT
SO THERE'S A MULTITUDE OF
REASONS OF WHY AN OPERATOR WOULD
CHOOSE TO. RUN AT LOW PRESSURE
AT WOULD BE OUR A-
COMPARATIVELY- LESS RESTRICTIVE.
INSPECTION REGIMENT B. ONE OF
THOSE REASONS. I'M NOT SURE I'M
I'M NOT SURE HOW BURDENSOME THAT
INSPECTION REQUIREMENT WOULD BE
IF THAT WOULD BE ENOUGH TO. HAVE
THEM RUN AT LOWER PRESSURE OKAY
THANK YOU. OTHER QUITE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- CHIEF OSTLER
MENTION INCREASE REGULATIONS
WERE PROPOSED VIA S. B. ONE
SIXTY NINE JACKSON. AS THAT BILL
DID NOT MAKE IT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATORS WHAT OTHER MEASURES
NOT ADDRESSED IN THAT BILL COULD
BE INDUCED NERDIST THAT WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL TO YOUR OFFICE AND
STATE TO ENSURE WE FIND
TROUBLESOME PLATFORMS AND MILES.
I BELIEVE THE QUESTION IS ARE
THERE ADDITIONAL ITEMS IN THAT
BILL THAT WOULD HELP. IS THAT A
CORRECT STATEMENT. YES SIR- I
BELIEVE THERE WERE SEVERAL OTHER
ITEMS THAT WOULD HELP US IN
THAT- PROFIT IN THAT THE BILL
ALSO- THERE ARE OTHER ITEMS THAT
COULD BE REVIEWED IN ANY OTHER
PART ONE AT THAT THE WE BELIEVE
WOULD BENEFIT THE- REGULATORY
ABILITY- THE STATE FARM ARE. I
KEEP JUST FOLLOWING UP ON THAT
QUESTION WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO
ELABORATE ON SOME OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. I THINK THEY
PROBABLY- DUE TO THE LIMITED
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE GOING ON
WITH ME I THINK THAT IT WOULD BE
BEST IF WE COULD- MEETING WITH
YOUR OFFICES AND- DISCUSS THAT
LEVEL OF DETAIL. AND PROVIDE
SOME OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU. YES
I THINK WE WILL CERTAINLY TAKE
THAT AS A FOLLOW UP FROM TWO
DAYS A CONVERSATION AND FIVE. IT
CERTAINLY DID SOUND FROM YOUR
TESTIMONY AS AS WELL AS AS FROM
YOUR IS THAT THERE IS. AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO STRENGTHEN
AND STATE REGULATIONS RELATED TO
LOW PRESSURE PIPELINES IN
PARTICULAR AND THAT THERE
CERTAINLY MAY BE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL. I'M SO IS
THAT AN ACCURATE CONCLUSION
CHIEF. I THINK THAT WOULD BE A
VERY ACCURATE STATEMENT. ARSENE
AND HEARING NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS- THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND PARTICIPATION
AND I CERTAINLY THINK THAT THERE
IS A LOT FOR US TO FOLLOW UP ON
ON BOTH WITH THE STATE FARM MARK
MARSHALS OFFICES WELL AS WITH
THAT THE PIPELINE SAFETY TRUST-
I THINK THAT THERE ARE. SOME
VERY CONCRETE. OPPORTUNITIES AND
PROPOSALS ON THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE TAKE FORWARD.
THANK YOU CHAIR ONE QUICK
COMMENT FROM THE EARLIER PANEL
THERE WAS TALK ABOUT THE-
MUNICIPAL OIL SPILL RESPONSE
PLANS I WANT TO POINT OUT A
POSSIBLE- FUNDING RESOURCE FOR
THAT KIND OF WORK AND- UP IN THE
HE'S BEEN DISCUSSED QUITE A BIT
TODAY HAS A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
GRANT PROGRAM. FOR
MUNICIPALITIES AND NON PROFITS
AND- OIL SPILL RESPONSE
RESOURCES WOULD FALL UNDER- THAT
GRANT PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR
HIGHLIGHTING NOT AT WITH THAT WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND DIVE CONCLUDE
THAT PANEL AGAIN THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THIS
CONVERSATION AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
WITH THAT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND-
THE BAN AFTER HEARING FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS. ON WE DO ASK IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME FOR ALL
SPEAKERS TO LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS
TO TWO MINUTES 4% SEVEN SURE
THERE'S TIME FOR ALL
PARTICIPANTS. I WILL FIRST BE
TAKING PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN THE
ROOM AND WE WILL ALSO BE OPENING
UP THE PHONE LINES AFTER OUR IN
PERSON TESTIMONY DOES AND AS A
REMINDER THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN THE ACCESS CODE IS.
TWO ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO. I IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
ON SERVICE YOU CAN CALL OUR
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2074 MY
STAFF WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
RECESSED I AND I WILL ALSO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. ARTS WALK UP WITH
THAT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WHO IS JOINING US IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND AND THAT WILL THEN.
ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. SIR. MY NAME DONE
GROUPS LOCAL RIGHT. THE. MY NAME
IS DON CRUZ I'M A LOCAL
RESIDENT- LOVER OF THE OCEAN
NUMBER THE DIVER FOR FIFTY
YEARS- AND I'M THE TYPE WHO
VOLUNTEER CRYSTAL COVE STATE
PARK. I HAVE TWO COMMENTS ONE
HAS TO DO WITH THE- ALL OF YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT MITIGATING AND
MINIMISING THE IMPACT THE SPILL.
AND YET I HEAR GARY BROWN TALK
ABOUT HOW. THE OIL COMPANIES
WOULD LIKE TO DECOMMISSION THESE
PLATFORMS. STOPPING OR
MINIMIZING THE IMPACT IS STILL
GOING TO HAVE IMPACT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE ECONOMIC AND
ECOLOGICAL DAMAGE. YOU HAVE TO
SHUT HIM DOWN TAKE ELIMINATE THE
ECONOMICAL DAMAGE ECONOMIC
DAMAGE. SO I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
POLITICIAN SAYING WE'RE GONNA
SHUT DOWN PUMPING OF OIL NOT
DRAWING. THANK MY SECOND COMMENT
HAS TO DO WITH THE CLEAN UP.
BEING ON THE BEACH A LOT I SAW
THESE PEOPLE CLEANING UP THE
BEACH M. A. HAD THE MOTIVATION
IN THE EDUCATION OF THE PRISON
GETTING CHANGE THE ASKED ME. I
VOLUNTEERED THROUGH FOUR
DIFFERENT. PATHS TO GET DOWN
THERE AND CLEAN UP I'M A TITLE
WHICH I LOVE THE OCEAN. AND I
WAS JUST IN ON ONE WITH A LOT OF
THOUSANDS OF OTHER PEOPLE.
TURNED AWAY BECAUSE THEY ALREADY
HAD THESE NON MOTIVATED PEOPLE
ON THE BEACH. SO I SEE THESE
PEOPLE NOT DOING A GOOD JOB. AND
I SEE THEM NOT CLEANING UP OIL
AFTER THEY'VE DONE THE INITIAL
HIGH MY WATERMARK AND I KNOW
THEY WERE CLEANING UP TITLES.
YOU WON'T YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO
STOP OIL DAMAGE. WITH JUST
MITIGATION IMPROVING YOUR
RESPONSE YOU HAVE TO SHUT DOWN
THE PUMP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. A IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM WITH LIKE TO- MAKE A
COMMENT EIGHTEEN AND HEARING
NINE I WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES. CALLER. EIGHT
ZERO EVEN GENERATE ALL THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
A COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
THE END OF THE ROW AT THIS TIME.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND THEN YOU OR GOING
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO LEARN HOW LONG POLICY
ADVOCATE OR IF YOU'RE GONNA
CALIFORNIA BERMAN BURGEONING
LOCAL CHAPTER AND HAPPILY MEMBER
ORDERED. STATE I CAN'T REMEMBER
THE CANADIAN WELL TALENTS OF THE
HEARING THE CONVERSATION THE ARE
A ON CHANNEL. EVERYONE THE HOME
NOW FOR THEIR BUT ALSO JOHN YOUR
AND HARMFUL OUR COMMUNITY AND
CRITICISM. IT UNBELIEVABLE A
WHOLE. NOT FOR TIME HOSTILITY
BECAUSE I A LITTLE BE LIKE A HOT
AND YET THEY WILL OPERATE MEDIAL
OF YOUR WELL WE WERE ALL. WITH
TO BE. THE ALSO OPTIONAL. THE
SERGEANTS ROUTINELY ALL. WE KNOW
IS WIRED A LITTLE COMPANY LONDON
ENGLAND WHY WILL NO. ABOUT A
MAJOR NEGATIVE. OPTICIAN CLASS
ON OUR PART HEALTH INCLINED IT
TOO LOUD OPERATE ABOUT OPERATION
TO BEGIN THAT- LONG HAVE OF MINE
TRANSITION AWAY FROM UNDER YOUR
DRILLING AND ADDITIONAL TO HELP
YOU IMPORTANT ENERGY FUTURE.
THANK. JERRY HEY ARE ABILITY TO
NEED TO BE- ALSO ON THE COURT HE-
THAT I BUT- SENATOR FOR. GLASS
ACTION THE TOP WHERE ALL
TOGETHER YOUR CHANNEL ACT MORE.
TELEVISION I DON'T I HE TURNED.
OUR JOSH. BOB FOR THE SENATE
OPERATOR OR YOU THE WHOLE I
DON'T WANT PAINFUL READING AND-
BUT A CALL FOR OF OUR. RIGHT NOW.
NOT ONLY THIS MONTH MENTIONED AT
WE ARE HE DIDN'T EVERY DAY THERE
WAS NO CHANGE IS A LONG AND NO
HAN AND THAT ACROSS WITH ALL
THESE KERN IT IS EXTRA INDUSTRY
NOT JUST IN ITALY CALIFORNIA BUT
ALL OVER THE WORLD. IT IS FOR
THE ONLY ONE. AND I WHY ALL
THESE ENTITIES ARE YOU
COMMITTEES AND COMMISSIONS AND
GOVERNMENT. DO NOT HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP. WITH A DOCUMENT IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND OR ALL THE
OTHER. TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
ALREADY. TO RECRUITING I. SAN
DIEGO. THE OCEAN THERE ARE
DIRECTLY EFFECT A CRIPPLING AND.
IN ORDER LIVE DOWN ON OUR CHURCH
WHAT WOULD YOU IF IT WERE DUMPED
ON YOUR BY ON YOUR CHURCH CAMP.
AND HER YOUR TO. FOR CHARGING
COMPANY REMOVED YOUR PIPELINE
YOU CAN CREATE THE HERE. AND
BEYOND IN A STORAGE UNIT-
BIRACIAL. THIS IS A HUGE. ARE
PLANET A COMMIT TO DO JUST.
RESPONSIBLE SHALL AND BY
HEADQUARTERS- CORPORATION. ARE
OFFERING THAT. TECH AUBURN FOR
THE ALL COUNTRY. I ATTENDED A ME
A BEER THEM FOR TAX AND I ABLE
TO. AND THERE ARE NEW ANY EXPERT
AND NOW ANY REFUSE FOR BOTH
FEDERAL LOCAL AGENCIES AND. ALL
THEY HAVE WELL IN AND ONLY. FUND
ACROSS AND- FINALLY HE WOULD
EVEN ACT WHAT TEXAS DOES THEY
ARE STATE TO CONTINUE THEIR IN
LEAK. NEED TO CLOSE OUT THE WELL
HI ALL ARE REGION. GOOD SEVEN
GENERAL THE BY EACH FOR IN THE-
MY- BELIEVE OR- PERSON AND
DIDN'T HERE THAT. ON MY DON'T
HAVE TO A I'M AT THE CAL POLY
FILED AND YOU ALL INTO AND
ENGAGING CAN YOU OVERSIGHT TO
RESPOND IF THE AFTER. AND CLOSE
ALL THE HYPE WHY. FOR HEALING
ARE FINE ARE WE THAT ARE. DO SO
IFFERENTLY WAIT A MINUTE
LEADERS. AND OUR OUR FOR ALL US
IN A IT ON THE CLIENT
RUDIMENTARY. HERE TO FURTHER IN
OUR OCEANS RT ARE WETLAND EARLY.
SYMBOL LIKE THANK YOU. AND THE
WORLD OCEAN WAVES AND BEACHES
FOR ALL PEOPLE TO ANALYZE
WHETHER YOU SELL A CORD LOCK
IRWIN COUNTY ALTADENA INDIVIDUAL
HOME YEAH- ACTION AND HAN THAT
PEOPLE. ARE LOOKING AT THIRTEEN
MILE OIL SLICK AND HE'S HE'S
ADMINISTERING CALDERON BINDING
AND IT WILL THE COMMUNITIES
BUSINESS AND OTHER OF THE
PUBLIC. AT THE ANNUAL MEETING ON%
UNITING ANSWERED ABOUT ASIAN HAS
BEEN DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN
SUPPORTING CLEAN UP EFFORTS WE
EXPRESS OUR SINCERE GRATITUDE.
THE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES TRAINING
PROFESSIONALS AND VOLUNTEERS AS
QUICKLY AS I CAN RESPOND AS
WARRANTED THE DOCTOR BEING MUCH
WORSE I DON'T ACTUALLY THE
COMEDY. WRITERS TODAY. JERRY
BROWN AND COME- DIRECTOR ON THE
CALIFORNIA WILL STILL HADN'T AND-
TO HAVE DURING LIFE AND HEALTH
WE DON'T TREAT ALL OUR HARSH.
ONE OF THE HOT IF SOUTH IN A
MINUTE WORKING ON THE IMPACT TO
THE WHAT AND- AS WELL WELL BIRDS.
BUT A LITTLE BIT IMPACTED IN
THIS TERM THE WHOLE SCALE THAT A
LOT DOWN WILL BE COME TO COME
CLEAR IN A WEEK STILL THAT WAS
LOOK AT. INTO AN HOUSE NUMBER
TERM AND NATION WALDRON OLD
BELIEVE. LOW YOU CAN ALSO FIND A
WAY. THE SHARES OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE TO INFORM THE
UNIFIED COMMAND RESPONSE. IT
PROVIDE THE HANDLE A FOR ABOUT
MINUTE. IT IS THE LEADING ACTION.
HELLO MY WILL BUILD NOT OUR
PASSAGE IT HUMAN ONE AS WELL
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD HEEDED AIR
SHOW ANYTHING BEACH SURF. WERE
HANDLED EVENT THE DRAWS LEAST
ONE OF FIVE PEOPLE THE CLOTHING
OF MY TO BE AND THE ROUTE. WHAT
AT LOAD OR COUNTY OCEAN AND
FURTHER ON WE IS VALUED AT MORE
THAN TWO POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS ACCORDING TO NATIONAL
OCEAN PROGRAM GONNA RESTAURANT
HOTELS AT THEIR SHOP AND I WANT
YOU TO WORK LOCAL ON. COMMUNITY
AND TO BE YOU'RE AND EVENT
LEGION. MOTOR DON'TBACK TODAY
AND WE'LL LAST UNTIL THAT LEAST
LATE NOVEMBER. THE ONLY NEWS
THAT OIL SPILL AND HAVE AND I OF
SUMMER DURING WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING US OPEN AFTER IN A
BATTLE WALDRON LEGAL STRUCTURE
WITHOUT TO THE PEOPLE AND VERY
TO ONE DOLLARS. IF YOU LIKE TO
SEE IS THAT THE OUR OUR INCLUDE
AND AREA COMMUNITY PLANS. YOU
CAN BE DIFFICULT. AND I NEED IN
A VERY NO THERE'S STILL- IT
REALLY STREAMLINED CUMBERSOME
PROCESS OF. WILL IT HAPPEN AGAIN
AND AGAIN. WE REQUEST YOUR
IMMEDIATE AT THE STATE WITH ARE
CRITICAL AND APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. THE LEADER. BUT IF AND
CLEANING AND EXISTING OFFSHORE
RIG. IN CALIFORNIA DELETED ALL
THE DATA AND WHEN ONLY AFTER
LEARNING ON LAND IS WELL
ACTUALLY HE'S A LITTLE HEALTH
AND CLIMATE CHANGE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE. THANK
YOU. ZERO NINE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT ISRAELI ACTION
REGULARLY LITTLE ANIMAL
DETERMINATION AT WORK IN THE
COMMUNITY TO PROTECT HER
ARTICLES. AND INFORMATION. AND
ENERGY TO NOT CARE I DON'T WANT
TO ENGAGE AND WE CAN LIVE
WITHOUT WELL WE'RE MONITORING
INTERNAL WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING WATER. AND LAND I. WE
HAVE A LOT OF. THAT BILLS WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE AND BECAUSE ALL
THREE MY IT IS NOT A GOOD IDEA
TO HER PLACE. IS BECAUSE- GOOD
MORNING SPEND TO KEEP AND GO.
RIGHT MORE DETAILS MORE PEACEFUL
AND THEN DO STILL HAVE TO BE
THEM IN THE FUTURE ONE INDUSTRY
I THINK PEOPLE ON PLANET
PROPERTY FROM CLEAN. GENERALLY
AND MANY OF THOSE RESIDENTS THE
BITTER COLD BECAUSE IT IS AN
AFFORDABLE WAY TO PRACTICE
MAJOR. MAJOR UNITY. THE ONLY
FIRST POLICY OIL DRILLING DOWN.
ANOTHER INDICATOR TO WE NEED
THAT NOW MORE THAT CAN BE SPENT
VERY PROFESSIONAL THE MORE THAN
LIKELY THEY ARE KEEP CALLING THE
OCEAN NONPROFIT CENTER IN THE
FINALLY MARTY THAT WE NEED TO
TREAT HER FOR ALL INFORMATION
INTELLIGENCE. THERE THANK YOU I
HAVE NO OVER COMMENT THANK YOU
AT THE TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATE. AND THAT THE WE CLOSE
OUT WITH. ANY MEMBERS IN THE
DIETS LIKE TO OFFER ANY CLOSING
REMARKS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. YEAH I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PATIENTS TODAY AND- GOOD JOB
CHAIR PETRIE-NORRIS ON- MAKE IT
ALL WORK- YOU KNOW I THINK WE'VE
HEARD AND RECOGNIZED A LOT OF-
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE WHILE
SOME OF THE AREAS WE NEED TO
IMPROVE AND I THINK THERE'S
REALLY A CALL FOR MORE HEARINGS
ON THIS ISSUE- WELL I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S RESTRICTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ONGOING
INVESTIGATIONS. AND THAT MAY
LIMIT WHAT CAN BE DISCUSSED IN
HEARING LIKE THIS I CONTINUE TO
REMAIN REMAIN CONCERNED THAT
THEIR SALIENT QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE SPELL THAT ABSOLUTELY NEED
TO BE ANSWERED IF WE'RE GOING TO
HELP CRAFT POLICIES TO HELP
SAFELY AND THE EXTRACTION OF OIL
OFF OUR COASTLINE. WHETHER IN
STATE OR FEDERAL WATERS. AS I
INDICATED BEFORE WELL THIS IS
FRAMED AS THE ORANGE COUNTY OIL
SPILL. IS HAS A VERY REAL IMPACT
ON SAN DIEGO COUNTY. AS WELL
THESE EVENTS SHOULD BE A MATTER
STATEWIDE CONCERNS. BECAUSE OIL
SPILLS ALONG OUR CALIFORNIA
COAST COASTLINE RECOGNIZE NO
ARBITRARY BOUNDARIES A FEDERAL
STATE WATERS LEGISLATIVE
DISTRICT OR CITY. SELL OUT
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO IT GOOD
JOB MANDA LET'S KEEP THE
MOMENTUM GOING WE KNOW WHEN THE
MEDIA TAKES THEIR AYE OFFICE.
AND KINDA FEELS LIKE THEY'VE
DROPPED THE ISSUE AND I THINK
THE FACT THAT WE'RE HERE TODAY
MEANS WE'RE NOT DROPPING THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PLAN THANK YOU I WANT TO START
OUT BY THANKING CHAIR
PETRIE-NORRIS INJURE RIVAS
CULTURE RIVAS FOR- OF PUTTING
THIS TOGETHER ALL OF OUR STAFF
TO WORK VERY HARD WITH THIS
HEARING TOGETHER- AND OF COURSE
HE SAID MY COLLEAGUES TO ADD-
THE PARTICIPANTS PANELISTS AND
TOUGH FOLKS WHO CAME HERE JUST
OUT OF INTEREST- BECAUSE THERE
IS INTENSE INTEREST AROUND- THIS
ISSUE. THE THING THAT STANDS OUT
TO ME- ARE THE MANY CONCRETE
SUGGESTIONS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE ARE TODAY AND- I KNOW
WE'LL ALL BE THINKING ABOUT-
WHICH OF THOSE IF NOT ALL OF
THEM- I WE WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON
IN THE UPCOMING LEGISLATIVE
SESSION- BUT- I THINK I CAN
SAFELY ASSURE. ANYBODY WHO'S
TUNING IN. TO THIS HEARING THAT-
WE HAVEN'T HEARD THE END OF THIS
ISSUE THAT THERE WILL BE
LEGISLATIVE AND BUDGETARY-
ACTION THAT WILL FOLLOW- ONCE WE
RECONVENE IN JANUARY IF NOT
BEFORE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RITA. I'D LIKE TO START
BY THANKING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND HER TEAM FOR
ORGANIZING THIS LOCAL HEARING IN
ORANGE COUNTY- YOU KNOW I KNOW
IT'S CHALLENGING- WHEN YOU PLAN
HEARING AWAY FROM THE CAPITAL
AND EVERYTHING THAT GOES INTO IT
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLY TEAM THE REST OF THE
ASSEMBLY SUPPORT TEAM THAT IS
HERE. TO MAKE THIS POSSIBLE
INCLUDING MY CHIEF CONSULTANT
FROM CHAIR OF NATURAL RESOURCE
FROM I MEAN THE NATURIST ARSES
COMMITTEE- AND OF COURSE THANKS
TO OUR OUR CO CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM FOR BEING HERE YOU
KNOW I KNOW THAT A LOT OF POLICY
IDEAS AND RECOMMENDATIONS WILL-
YOU KNOW RESULT AS YOU KNOW WILL
BE A RESULT OF THIS HEARING. AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
MY COLLEAGUES ON POLICY IDEAS
AND HAVING THOSE DISCUSSIONS AS
WE HEAD BACK TO SACRAMENTO IN
JANUARY- YOU KNOW MY CONSULTANTS
ON NATURAL RESOURCES ARE READY
TO WORK WITH LEGISLATORS ODD
YEAR OLD MAKING THESE IDEAS INTO
POTENTIAL LEGISLATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU AGAIN I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THINK- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND YOUR TEAM FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER AS QUICKLY
AS YOU DID OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
GOING TO BE THE FIRST OF MANY
MEETINGS AND I THINK WAS A GREAT
START I THINK ON THERE'S A LOT
OF GREAT IDEAS COMING AND
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED TO INCREASE
OUR TECHNOLOGY. WE NEED TO
INCREASE OUR EDUCATION AND WE
NEED TO LOOK AT GOOD POLICY AND
WHEN THE QUESTIONS I HAVE IS
ACTUALLY ANSWERED BY THE
GENTLEMAN ON THE LAST PANEL AND
IT REALLY WAS IS THAT A LOT OF
THE STATE'S OF GOT GOOD- POLICY
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT FIRST BEFORE
TRYING TO REINVENT THE WHEEL
ITSELF I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO SEE THE POLICY
THAT'S WORKING FOR THEM AND HOW
THAT IS YOU KNOW REALLY A GOOD
SAFETY I'M NOT SURE THAT THEY
HAVE SO. LET'S LOOK AT THAT AND
PERHAPS WE CAN TAKE THAT
TOGETHER TO GET ON THE ON SB
BUILD PREDECESSORS- ITEMS THERE
TOO THAT WE CAN WORK TOGETHER ON
POLICY I FEEL HOPEFUL THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY MAKE A CHANGE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AT THE
MEMBER WHEN. THEY THANK YOU MAY.
CHAIR I AM. ALSO WANT TO THANK
MANAGE FOR AND YOUR TEAM FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER. WHAT I
THINK ALL THE PANELS AS WELL
TODAY. FOUR VERY INFORMATIVE
INFORMATION AND THINKING. OF MY
MAYOR AS WELL FOR COMING HERE
LETTING US KNOW. WHAT SHE HAS
DONE. WHAT HAD TO BE TESTED AND-
JUST YOU KNOW AT. IT I AGREE
THIS IS A GREAT START- I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THERE BE MANY MORE.
AND I HOPE THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. WE NEED TO YOU KNOW
DISCUSS ABOUT YOU KNOW. COMMAND
CENTERS SHOULD BE. NEAR THE
LOCATION OF THE INCIDENT. AND
NOT ANOTHER COUNTY- THAT'S ONE
THING THAT I THINK. MADE A VERY
CHALLENGING FOR A LOT OF US.
WHEN THE START OF IT THE COMMAND
CENTER WAS IN LONG BEACH. AND
QUITE FAR AWAY. OF A GOOD DEAL
TWENTY MINUTES FROM MY DISTRICT
WHICH IMAX BORDER LONG BEACH-
BUT YOU KNOW AND FOUR OTHER
MEMBERS LIKE THE CHAIR AND OTHER
MEMBERS. THAT HAS THE COASTAL-
DOWN FOR THE SOUTH THAT'S A GOOD
HOUR JUST TO GET TO THE COMMAND
CENTER. SO I'M OPEN THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT I'M HOPING
THAT WE WOULD ALSO BRING IN THE
OIL INDUSTRY. AND ALSO THE LABOR
UNIONS. THAT WORK. WITHIN THE
PORT AREA AND- AND BRING IN THE
PORT. BECAUSE THE CAN OCCUR
AGAIN IF THOSE CARGO SHIP
CONTINUES TO SIT THERE. AND IT'S
NOT MOVING I'M SORRY IF ANYBODY
TELLS ME THEIR MOVIE YES THEY
MOVED IS MORE THAT'S COMING. AND
SO YOU KNOW WE GET TO SEE IT
ALONG THE ENTIRE COAST OF ORANGE
COUNTY. AND IT'S ALL A BIT START
FOR MY DISTRICT HAS AGAIN I'M
BORED I BORDER LONG BEACH WHICH
SUPPORT OF LONG BEACH AND SO YOU
KNOW NOT ONLY IT'S FOR THE
SAFETY OF. OF THE PEOPLE THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE WILDLIFE BUT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT NOBLE
CARGO SHIPS- ANCHORS IN AND NOT
KNOW WHERE THESE PIPELINES ARE
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT THESE
PIPELINES ARE I KNOW THERE'S GOT
TO BE A MAP AND I KNOW THERE.
THE SHARE FASCI SHERIFF
DEPARTMENT CAME UP TO ME SAID
THERE IS A MAP OF ALL THE
PIPELINES I WOULD LIKE TO GET
THE- I WOULD LIKE YOU KNOW MAYBE
IF MEDICARE CAN. I DON'T KNOW
WHICH DEPARTMENT WE WOULD NEED
TO GO TO BUT GET THE MAPS OF ALL
THE PIPELINES. WHERE THEY ARE
AND NOT JUST ORANGE COUNTY BUT
WHERE THEY ARE IN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL HOW MANY ARE THERE. HOW OLD
THEY ARE THE JUST BASIC
INFORMATION OF WHERE WHAT THESE
PIPELINES AND YOU KNOW WHERE
THEY TO HELP WHEN THESE WERE
BUILT. HOW LONG THEY'VE BEEN
BUILT WHO'S MANAGING THEM WHO
OWNS THEM- ARE THEY- STILL
WORKING OR DID NOT. OF EIGHTEEN
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR US
JUST TO LOOK AT. THESE BASIC
FIRST AS WELL- AND YOU KNOW AND
SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME. TO BE
PART OF THE PANEL. AND THANK YOU
AND NOT YES CERTAINLY WE WILL
TAKE THAT AS AN ACTION ITEM
MOVING FORWARD. BOB AND- THAT
THE REALITY IS THAT. WE'VE THERE
ARE A TWENTY THREE PLATFORMS IN
FEDERAL WATERS THERE'S FOUR
PLATFORMS IN STATE WATERS WHICH
DOESN'T REALLY MAYBE DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE THAT BIG A NUMBER BUT
EACH OF THESE PLATFORMS ARE
CONNECTED TO. SOME CASES
HUNDREDS OF PIPELINES SO THE
MATH AND YES WILL FOLLOW UP AND
ENSURE YOU THAT IT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S LIKE A SPIDER WEB IT'S A
SPIDER WEB AND EVERY STRAND OF
THAT WRECK WEBER. REPRESENTS A
THREAT AND A RISK TO OUR
COMMUNITY. AND TO OUR HOME AND
LIKE SO MANY OF THE MEMBERS THAT
ARE HERE TODAY AS PART OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT
ON THIS AND A CHERRY BLOOM.
JERRY THIS BIRD OFF FOR. HELPING
US PUT TOGETHER THIS HEARING. WE
AND THREE THE FOLKS WHO HEARD
FROM TODAY WE ARE SO BLESSED TO
CALL THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COAST OUR HOME. I FEEL
PROFOUNDLY BLESSED TO WAKE UP
EACH AND EVERY DAY AND CALL THIS
MY HOME. AND I. THINK THAT THIS
SPELL FOR MANY OF US HAS REALLY
BEEN A CALL. TO ACTION. AND OUT
WHILE THE GOAL OF THIS COMMITTEE
IS CERTAINLY IS CERTAINLY TO
LEARN THE DESERT FROM THIS
DISASTER AND ENSURE THAT WE DO
NOT. REPEAT THE TRAGEDY THAT THE
REALITY IS THAT THE FUNDAMENTAL
LESSON FROM THIS BILL IS REALLY
REALLY SIMPLE. BUT SEVEN AM
BLOOM SAID IN HIS OPENING
REMARKS WHEN THERE'S DRILLING
THERE IS SPELLING AND CERTAINLY
THIS DOES. I THINK DRIVE HOME
FOR ALL OF US THAT THE TIME TO.
AND AFTER DRILLING ALONG THE
COAST IT IS LONG PAST IT IS LONG
PAST TIME. AND FIVE I BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE HERE AS STEWARDS OF.
OUR OCEANS WERE HERE'S STEWARDS
OF OUR PLANET AND- I DO BELIEVE
THAT. THIS DISASTER IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO MAKE REAL
AND LASTING CHANGES AND FOR THIS
NOT TO JUST BE A- YEAH BUT NOTE.
ABOUT AND ANOTHER DISASTER BUT A
TIME WHEN WE REALLY DO YOU USE
THIS. HE THAT CALL TO ACTION AND
USE THIS AS A TURNING POINT I TO
MOVE CALIFORNIA FORWARD TO. LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL OF YOU ARE ON. THAT
IMPORTANT WORK AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO. WORK TOGETHER
TO. TURN THE CORNER AND BUILD
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE. I WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED AND CHAT WE WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO WELCOMING YOU TO THE
NEXT HEARING IN JANUARY.